learn how to build and deploy a full
stack notion clone using nexs 13 Dolly
and versel you'll style the app using
Shad Cen and Tailwind CSS you'll also
learn how to interact with databases
with the efficiency of orms Elliot Chong
created this course he specializes in
creating comprehensive tutorials on how
to build AI powered
applications hi what's Poppin I'm Elliot
a web developer from Singapore and today
here I have a build for you that is a
notion plus AI clone so basically what I
does is a AI note taking assistant so
it's kind of like notion where you have
a buin editor where you can type your
text and there will be an AI integration
with it so let's just show you what I
mean so here we can see that it's
deployed to versel right using nextjs
and you can press get started and
basically will'll be using click uh
click authentication for this app so we
can either sign in with Google or GitHub
and we'll press authorize so I'm going
to show you how to build this entire
thing and deploy it from scratch so you
can see we land in this beautiful
dashboard right we're able to see all
notebooks and all these images today
we'll be using learning how to use the
open AI di API so if you're not sure do
is a uh di is an image generation is a
text to image model developed by open AI
so we I'll be teaching you how to use
your API to actually generate these
images that's relevant to uh the links
okay so let me just show you an example
of how it looks like so we can here we
can create a new notebook so you can
name anything you want like let's say
cats all right so basically what this
does it will hit the verel API and this
API will be running on the edge so I
explain what the edge is but basically
this age uh run time will allow you to
run uh AI functions for much longer and
it's much faster also so the reason why
it's taking a little while is because
it's trying to generate the image so
that takes about a few seconds after
you've generated it brings you to this
really nice what you see is what you get
editor where you can start typing your
notes like uh hello and you can even
like have functions like italicize it or
strike through it or you can make make
it into a code block right here's
another code block you can type in like
JavaScript functions or anything right
just to take notes okay but what's
really cool about this and what I'm
really happy to show you today is you
can write you can have ai auto complete
so here I can write like uh cats R right
and let's say I'm trying to think of
something I can press shift a right and
it's going to have a AI generated you
can see the AI is going to be uh
basically trying to complete my sentence
so here it generate that cats are
mysterious creatures with eyes the same
whole world of Secrets right we can
basically it just uh it's a very nice AI
functionality and be using the versal AI
SDK right to actually uh make this
streaming feature so you can see that as
we type like let's say we can say that
uh what else uh cats and docs R and
let's try the auto complete are not just
pets but also Guardians Of Secrets right
so it's a very nice uh cool feature that
you can help uh in your writing
assistant yeah so be building everything
from scratch deploying it I'll teach you
how to how to make all this uh what you
see is what you get editor you can have
like list and stuff so you can really
make uh make this into like your daily
editor where you can just type notes and
have ai to assist you and you can see
there auto save feature so all of these
notes are saved to the database so you
can see that even if you refresh right
the the the the data is being persisted
and we'll be using a database called
neon DB which is a serverless postgress
database yeah so if you come back here
right if you come back to uh the
dashboard right and we refresh the page
we can see that the cats has been
generated so there's a image that's
using Dar API to generate a notebook uh
profile thumbnail image to fit whatever
name that we have G given it so all this
will be using prompt engineering yeah so
it's quite a simple short build but I
just want to go through how we can build
this out
today all right so after looking at the
demo I'm going to go through a little of
what we'll be learning today an overview
so we'll be using next gs13 with the app
directory for this app we'll be using
shat CN which is a tailn CSS Library uh
that is very accessible and comes with a
lot of nice user interfaces components
of the box for us to use and be
obviously using open AI for the dly text
image generation and also the auto
complete uh note feature and number four
we learning about the versal H run time
so because normally versel free tier
allows your your apis to actually run
for only 5 Seconds right but then the
API like the open ai ai image
Generations will take about 8 to 10
seconds so if we use a normal uh versal
runtime without the age run time it's
going to basically uh time out and then
it won't allow your function to run it
won't allow the AI to generate the image
before expiring the API therefore if you
run the versel on this a special age run
time it allows us to run the function
for much longer and make it much faster
okay for our orm we'll be using dzo RM
so this is a new orm that is um in
competition with Prisma right it's a
it's a typescript object relational
mapper that allows uh interacting with
your SQL databas is much easier and give
you type safety and we'll be using neon
database as I said just now and for
number seven we'll be using Firebase
storage to save all the files right so
you can see that here all these images
that's generated it'll be stored in our
filebase app so then we can access the
URL through there then we'll be using
this for the node editor we'll be using
this Library called tip tab uh tip tab
node editor right which is another
library to basically help you make this
kind of very full flet uh very full flet
what you see is what you get editor and
lastly the versel AI SDK will help us
tie the uh front end to the AI back end
all right so uh let us get started so
here I'm going to open up my terminal
and let us do uh let us do to create the
next GS project let's do MPX create-x
app at latest with the typescript flag
so press that it's going to ask us for
the project name right it's going to ask
us to install the latest version first
and then it's going to ask us the for
the project name in this case I'm going
to do ideation D YouTube so it's just a
nice P like AI idation D YouTube so
let's just press enter we'll be using ES
lint to in CSS we'll be using the source
directory and the app router so this is
new within xjs the3 and also we'll be uh
just leave everything on default and
then when it's done I'm going to come
back to you okay so now that the next sh
project has finished initializing I'm
going to do CD adiation Das YouTube then
let us do code dot to open up this
folder in our vs code editor okay
excellent
I'm close down this terminal first let's
expand the code and what I'm going to do
here now first is I'm going to run uh
mpm run death right to make sure that
the next sh project is up and running so
I'm going to come back to my uh browser
here I'm going to open up Local Host
3,000 okay and what I'm going to do here
is I'm just going to open this up to the
right and then the code on the left so
that we can see what's happening all
right so here we have the next project
next project that running and that's
good that means everything is working
all right so let me just uh walk you
through about how the project structure
is going to look like so here you can
see that it's running on XS
13.5.3 right and so there's this new app
directory so you see if you go into the
source folder you can see there's this
new app directory so how the layout how
the navigation is done in Nexus 13.4 is
through this special page. TSX so this
page. TSX is a special F name right and
is is basically doing file based routing
so any folder uh inside this app
directory that contains this page. TSX
will be mapped to the file to the to the
route name so because this page. TSX
live in the root of this app we can see
that it maps to this uh root uh root URL
so this basically this file here in this
page of TSX map to whatever is shown
here in this page so what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to uh just return a
normal H1 that have a class name of text
rate 600 right and say hello world so
I'm going to test out TN CSS so because
next J didn't really comes with TN CSS
when we initialize it and we can see
that it works so we know that tawin CSS
is working okay so now that we have set
up TN CSS and nextjs let's not install
shet yet so if you're unfamiliar with
shetsen Shen is this very beautiful
component Library uh with beautifully
designed components that we can copy and
paste into our apps and is fully
accessible and customizable and this is
all built on rtics UI and PN CSS so you
can see it really give us very nice
beautiful user interfaces
right which we can just use directly
into our app so to set up Shen right
come come back down to your terminal and
what you got to do is going to run this
command MPX shed uh cn- UI at latest in
it so to initialize the shed CN
application right then it's going to ask
us if you're using typescript we press
yes then it ask us which St we can leave
as default and leave the color Bas color
as default it's going to ask us where
our global. CSS is right right now we
can see that there this s/ appg global.
CS s right this is this comes with the
in like the default default nextg
project what I want to do is delete this
Global s CSS I'm going override it in
this uh in the shn file so because we
want shn to handle all selling for us so
we can tell the global sour CSS lives in
sourcea global. CSS okay Enter and it's
going ask us if you want to use CSS
variables press yes and it us where our
Tailwind config is so in this case we we
using typescript so the tailn config
actually lives in T.C
config.inc
config.sys as default and the import
alas for utilities as default and lastly
we're using react s components press yes
it ask us if want to write the
configuration to components. Json so
it's just writing the configurations to
a file to be saved by shm okay perfect
so now we can see that uh there this new
components. Json file here and basically
it contains all the it contains all the
configuration that we just entered in
the terminal all right so how do we
actually start using shs yet so imagine
I to use like a button component right
so for now I'm just going to uh I'm
going to restart the server right and
then let's see what's what's happening
so let's come back to page. TSX all
right so right now it's uh it's it's Bri
color so everything is been reseted but
let's say I want to install uh the
shetan button so whenever you want to
use a new component within Shen you have
to manually install it and this is a
good thing because you only install the
components you need and the components
you don't need will not be built into
your app as a final production okay so
you want to install a new button you do
MPX sh uh sh cn- UI at latest add button
so you can add the button component it's
going to ask you if you want to confirm
so just uh just install the button it's
automatically going to install it and
let's see where it installs it in so we
can see that under Source app we can now
see there's a new components folder if
you go into components right we can see
that this is uh there's this UI folder
and within the UI folder is this button
TSX so this button. TSX is basically
what is generated by Shen right it uses
this like called class variance auality
authority to basically give us the
styling for using TN CSS to give us the
styling for uh different variants of the
pre-art button so you never really need
to go into this file to touch the
buttons right all you need to do is know
that this file exists and you can use it
so I'm going to close it out and how do
you actually use it so instead of
returning a H1 I'm going to just in
return a button and we can see that this
is automate imported from ui/ button so
let me just press enter Auto Import and
going to say click me so let me save
that and now you can see that the button
is showing up so we have successfully
installed sh
CN all right so now that we have set up
shat CN let's now go on to next step of
uh installing our cler so cler we'll be
using clerk.com uh for this for the
authentication part right cler is a
really it's a beautiful framework it's a
beautiful library that makes
authentication so easy and simple so I'm
going to teach you how to use it so come
down to cl.com and you have to log in to
the account or sign up and after that
you can come down to your dashboard so
in the dashboard you're able to see all
the different apps that you have made
all right so in this case I'm going to
add a new application and I'm going to
zoom in here and we're going to
basically name it uh ai ai dation all
right YouTube okay and then it's asking
us how will user sign in so you can
choose email as default I'm going to
turn it off because I only want to let
them sign in using Google and also uh
GitHub so YouTube uh Google and GitHub
for now and you can choose and T Go on
whatever methods you want them to sign
in so then after you have chosen just
press create application and you will
create a it'll create the secret keys
for you to use in your application so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
come down here and I'm going to press
continue IND dos CU we're using next 1
right so continue Indo so let's follow
the instructions on how to actually use
this uh use this Library so the first
step is to install cl/ nexts so I'm
going to install it I'm going to follow
the instructions so come down to my
terminal I'm going to do mpm install at
clerk / nextjs okay so now that we've
installed it let us actually put out
environmental keys so come down to your
file directory in the root file folder
all right on the root folder create a
newv file and one more thing to know is
come down to your gor and I want to add
the EnV extension to the gor so that
this is so that the environmental file
does not get committed into your git
repository and does not get pushed up to
GitHub later on right so because you
don't want people to see your secret
keys because they can easily abuse it
therefore we're adding this.v into the G
ignore okay so let us now continue
pasting in this uh these two keys into
the EnV so we'll place it in and save it
so now we have this uh next public uh
next cler public cler publishable key
and the secret key now let's go on to
the third step which is to mount the
cler provider right so we need this cler
provider to wrap our entire application
to give the entire application the
context of who's the currently loog in
user and whether they even Lo Lo in so
come down to layout. TSX right so this
layout. TS is basically what WS the
entire application and what I'm going to
do is here I'm going to just import
import uh from at cl/ next year so this
is a li a library we just mpm installed
just now and I want to uh import this CL
provider right then I'm going to come
down to this return I'm going to just
wrap the entire application in the CL
provider just wrap it here and save it
all right so that's good and now uh
since we're in layout let me talk about
this metadata so this metadata is just
uh what DET takes what is shown on this
uh you can see that there is this the
tab is create next app right so this is
what corresponds to the title tab the
tab title so you can just change it to
let's say
iation or YouTube then you can just
delete the description so if we save it
now we can see the tab name has changed
to match the idation YouTube
here okay that's good so so now let's
continue following on the cler
documentation there's a few more things
that we need to do okay so number four
is protect our application so now we
this protect our application we need to
create a new middleware dots so this
middleware dots is a special file within
nextjs that basically allows code to run
before every request so before you
navigate to any page or you try to hit
any end point right it will run this
middleware TS a code simple first right
so we can use this middleware TS to
basically control a whether these users
locked in and if they locked in we want
to protect certain pages so what I'm
going to come down to do is come down to
your Source folder inside the source
folder create a middle middleware TS
file right and going just copy in the
code from the CL documentation in here
so basically what it does is import this
off middleware from the library and then
export a default function here so this
basically protects all the routes right
it protects all the route so that anyone
who's um how say uh are not not loged in
they cannot access any routes and they
are forced to sign in right so we
actually do not want that to happen
because we want to basically allow this
public routs we want to allow a
non-login user to to access this uh SL
drop so this SL drop is like the
homepage so if you can see the in the
deploy application right we can see that
this is a SL the homepage right where
want all everyone can access therefore
we're going to basically add this slash
to the public routes array okay so now
that we have set up middleware dots let
us move on so okay so for this sign up
sign sign up Pages I'm going to come
down to my source directory come down to
app and create a new folder called sign-
up then within the sign- up let's create
a two angle brackets dot dot do sign- up
right then within this folder we can
finally create a page.
TSX okay so for this page. TSX I'm going
to import this uh import this default
sign up component so they already
pre-art a UI for us so I'm going to save
it
okay so we have copied in the default
sign up component and now let's do the
signin page so come down to your app uh
app folder again and create a sign sign
Das in folder within that do bracket
bracket do do do sign Dash in right then
under that we can just actually this
should be a folder not a file so let's
do that so it be a folder called d uh
bracket
bracket sign Dash in right then inside
here we can do a page. TSX and let's
create a copy in the default signin
component from cl/
nextjs okay then now we need to update
our environmental variables right let me
just zoom in here a little right so we
need this environmental variables to
basically tell cler which is our sign in
and sign up pages so come down to your
EnV file again and now under the CL uh
secret key let us do let us copy this
four variables in right so these four
variables basically tell cler which is
your sign in and sign up URL so we have
ma the signin URL to/ sign up sign in
and sign up right following the folder
structure here so we leave that as
default but here we can also configure
uh what happens after we sign in and
what happens after we sign up so after
we have signed in let's redirect them to
the/ dashboard page and after they have
signed up we so let us lead them to the/
dashboard page so let's save that and
now uh if you come back to our Local
Host 3000 right so Local Host 3000 right
here is our default page but now if you
go to slash uh SL sign Das up right we
can see that it BR brings us to this
custom component here so this maps to
the sign up page uh here that we have
this a sign up component here okay so
that's good so one more thing here I'm
just going to Center I'm just going to
try to Center this component in the
middle of the screen right so I'm going
to just return a a diff that just have a
class name of position absolute top of
half left of half negative translates X
of half and negative Translate it
Translate Y of half and then let me just
return this component so if we do that
now we can see that if you remove that
semicolon right we can see that the
component is centered in the screen
right and then we can also sign up and
just continue with GitHub so I'm going
to do the same with the sign in
component so I'm going copy this come
back down to my sign in
component right and then I'm me just do
the same return
this okay but this time will be the sign
in component so let's say this and now
you can see that if you come down to
sign in page it's also properly centered
in the screen so I'm going to come and
sign up and basically come down to
continue with my GitHub or Google
account okay so then it's going to just
redirect me to the GitHub o page and
since and now you can see we can see
that after we have signed in it brought
us to/ dashboard exactly what we asked
cler to
do okay so now that it has redirect us
to the dashboard let us actually not do
that first I want to actually finish up
my Landing page right so you can see in
the deploy application there's this very
nice uh big title with this typewriter
effect so I'm going to build out this
page first for us okay so I'm going to
just close down all my tabs here come
down to our page. TSX so this is where
we rendered this button so I'm going to
basically make that into the landing
page so the first thing here is I'm
going to do is uh I'm going to just uh
delete this and want to return a a diff
right sorry this will be a diff so this
diff let us give you a class name of a b
gradient from to right right so it goes
to the right and let us give you a mean
height of screen from rows 100 to T to
T 100 right so this is from like this
Dash right so if you save it right now
you can see there this nice gradient
from this rose color to this K color
okay and one more thing I add here is
you can see that this a very greeny R
slight greeny effect that I really love
right so I'm going to try I'm going to
show you how to actually add this greeny
effect so if you come down to your uh
Global s CSS Global CSS right underneath
close on this layer base right so these
are all basically shed CN and TN CSS
configuration right so what want to do
is um come down to this create a new
class called greeny it's a custom class
and we have a background image of of
this uh this URL so let me just copy
from down here right so don't worry I'll
give you the link I'll give you uh a
page bin to this background image but
basically this background image is just
a a green effect right so this
background image if you like if you
inspect it it's going to be greeny
effect so uh we can just use this greeny
and in our app so let me just save this
come down to our page here right so
right now we can see that it's not
grainy right so if you add one more
class here that says grainy and let's
save it now you can see there's this new
greeny effect on our app yeah so that's
a very simple and nice touch to make the
UI a lot nicer okay so within this diff
let us have another diff that wraps to
make everything centered so let me have
a diff here and the class name will be
position absolute top of half left of
half negative translate X of half and
negative Translate Y of half right then
this will Center everything here and
within it let me just put a H1 that has
a class name of uh let's give it font
semi B Tex 7 XL to make it huge and
let's Center by doing Tex center with h
the H1 let's just do AI uh note taking
assistant right then if you see that now
we can see there this AI note taking
assistant in the middle of the screen so
let me just put uh this green color in
the note taking right so make this note
taking green color to do that I'm going
to wrap uh this note taking in a span
right so I'm going to just take this
note taking here and put it in the span
okay and within this span let us give
you a class name of uh text green 600
and font
Bol font Bool okay so now we can see
this AI take note taking assistant much
nicer now okay right we can see that
this looks looks nicer and let me just
give you some space so in front of this
assistant let us put this space block
here so that it shows up nicely okay so
underneath the H1 uh let's have a spacer
so just do mt4 sorry mt-4 so this is
just a MTD element with a margin top of
four so then we can put our a typewriter
title here so for this typewriter title
let me just put a H2 here and give a
class name of font semi board text
3XL text of Center and text slit of
sorry text- slit of 700 and here I just
put AI uh forward save it so right now
we can see that it's just a normal text
right but we want this we want this like
a nice type rer effect so let's create a
separate component for the typewriter
effect come down to your directory come
down to your components right right so
we can see the component has a UI folder
but we don't to create it within the UI
folder because whatever in the UI folder
is handled by shn we want to create I
would think within the component folder
itself so inside components let us
create a new uh file let's just call it
typ writer title.
TSX okay then for this type riter title
let's actually do tsfc so this tsfc is a
is a extension snipper in vs code that
give me the typescript react Arrow
function exper component right so is
under this extension called I think
es7 snippers or something yeah uh sniper
yeah simple extension Snippets you can
install that for yourself so it will
give me this uh command right and then
with here let's actually make the
typewriter effect and we have a library
for that right like everything in
JavaScript there's always library for
whatever things you want so let's
install the library for the typew
writing effect so do mpm install
typewriter D
effect okay so once we have installed
that let's actually import it to use it
so uh import type Rider from type Rider
effect okay so then with here I'm just
return the type
Rider okay let's pass in the op some
options right so we want it to Loop to
Loop indefinitely forever and then here
we can actually uh basically tell it
what kind of things to type out so on in
it we can just um destructure out this
typew
riter uh we can actually Dru we can just
take the type typew
riter right and what you want to do with
this typew riter right so we have a lot
of different things we can just do
typewriter do type string so the first
string we want to type is um basically
we can just choose a emoji and a tag
line so in this case I'm just going to
just copy this TCH line in right so you
can write whever you want right I'm just
going to put this here so the first
thing is it's going to type out this
supercharge productivity right so I'm
going to save it first and then come
back to our page. DSX and I'm going to
import the typewriter title uh component
here so if you save it right now we can
see that
okay must be either now so one more
thing we need to do here is come back to
your typewriter title we need to make
this into a client component so because
this next Yer every component is by
default server component right so now we
can see that if you refresh it should uh
type type it out right but we haven't
started it so to actually start typing
we have to do do start so if we save it
now we can see that you should start
typing let us refresh the page and let's
see what it does and now we can see it
starts typing
and then because it we put loop as true
it's going to basically loop back delete
all the words and just loop back right
so let's actually add more stuff let's
say we can do so after he has typed let
us just pause for maybe uh pause for
1,000 milliseconds which is 1 second so
after pausing let us delete all and then
we can do the next type so we type
string again so then we can type out
another thing like let's say uh copy
this in type out AI power insight okay
so let's save it and yeah that's pretty
much it so you can add however more like
imperative uh typing you want so we can
type then pause and delete then type
then basically you just have this right
cool typewriter effect where you're just
typing out the different tag lines you
have for your application yeah so that's
pretty much it it's quite simple for the
the homepage so let me see if there's
anything else that we need for the
homepage okay so now let's actually add
the button to go to the dashboard so
underneath the H2 let's have another
spacer called mt-8 so it's another empty
diff with the margin top of eight right
to give you some a margin here and let
us have a diff here uh that has a let me
see let us just remove that diff
actually so below the spacer right so I
messed it up here so let us actually
have the link so this link come from
next Das link right we want to basically
link it to the SL dashboard and inside
the link
let's show a button so this button will
have a class name of BG D green- 600
then within it let us just do get
started right and then let save it and
so now we can see there a new button
here okay so let's Center this let's
Center this in the middle of the screen
right so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to just wrap this in another
diff and this div will have a class name
of flex and justify Center so this will
just Center the button in the middle of
the screen and let me just add the icon
right you can see there's icon nice icon
here so for icons for the icons will'll
be using this package called Lucid react
mkm install Lucid D react so it's a icon
Library if you have not seen before
Lucid if you go to Lucid def it just
provides us with Rand nice UI uh icons
for us to use within our
application okay so inside this button
like just beside this get started let us
have a a call Arrow right so let's
import this Arrow right icon from L
react so import from Lu D react so what
try import the arrow right icon okay so
this Arrow right let's give you some
styling of margin left of two width of
five and height of five and we give a
stroke width of short WID of let's
say sorry three three so now it looks
much nicer here with a button so if you
click on this we can see that it will
lead us to the dashboard right which we
have not created yet so that's good we
have created the uh landing page so
that's
good all right so now that we have
completed the homepage let's actually
work on the dashboard page so come down
to your directory sorry come down to
your folder here and come down to your
app and let's actually create a new
folder called dashboard then within the
dashboard let's create the special page.
TSX so then this will map to whatever
shown here so let's do TS R FC to create
the react component and let's just name
it to dashboard page so if you save it
now we can see the dashboard page
showing up here okay so let's actually
build out the user interface for the
dashboard so I'm going to come down here
I'm going to delete this I'm going to
return a uh react fragment and within
here let us have a a diff that have a
class name of grainy so we have the
grainy background again just now and a
minimum height of screen and if you save
it right now you can see the greeny
background showing up here all right
within the within this diff let's
actually have another diff uh sorry diff
they have a class name of a Max width of
7 XL and margin X of Auto and also
padding of 10 within this second inner
diff let's have a basically uh a empty
diff with a height of 14 so here just
another spacer empty D with a space of
uh height of 14 just to space out the
element a little right and then let's
have another diff in here and this diff
is going to what is going to be showing
the let me go to the deploy app it's
going to show us the this my notes the
back button and our user profile here
okay so for this diff let's give you a
class name of um Flex justify between
items items Das center right then when
we on the medium screen we want it to be
Flex Dash row but on the small screen
like mobile we want to be Flex column so
we can see that this a responsive
element to it so we can see that it's
responsive like this okay so come back
down to your local host uh let me just
move this here
okay so within this uh within this Flex
uh container let have another diff that
have just uh with a class name
of class name of flex and items Das
Center and within this item Center diff
let us have a link right this link come
from uh come from next SL link not Lucid
D react right come from next SL link
let's have a HRA to the slash so this is
the back button so let's import the
button and let's just do back so let's
save it and now we have this back button
showing up here okay let's give you some
styling uh I'm going to just have a uh
within this button let's have a arrow
left icon from lucd D react right he has
a class name of margin right of one
width of four and height of four
so now we can see that it just adds
arrow to the button and then for the
button let us give a class name of BG
green of 600 all right to match the
theme of our
application okay then below this link
right below this link let us have a
another diff right this has a diff of
it's empty diff of with D4 so it's just
not spacer element right and then here
we have a H1 that says my notes so give
let's say give this H1 some class names
of text- 3XL font Bo and text- g- 900 so
we save it now we have this uh it just
put it side by
side the H1 let's have another another
spacer diff of with das4 so it's not
empty diff and let's here let's put a
user button so this user button you can
see is imported from cl/ nextjs so there
is a pre uh pre-built button component
for us right that shows us that allows
us to see our profile image and manage
accounts and even lock us out if you
want to here okay so that's pretty much
it for like you see this top top bar
here right so you can see this on here
the button is a little smaller so we can
do that here by coming into the button
and let's pass a sizing of SM here so we
just make the button a little
smaller okay that's good so now that we
have that let's actually build the
spacer and the The Notebook list all
right
so underneath the underneath the user
button we have this diff right and then
we come down to this diff again right so
basically above the two closing diff we
have another spacer uh height d8 spacer
and then here we have a uh separator so
we this separator comes from Shen so
let's add that component so MPX Shen at
UI at latest at separator so you just
add the component into our project then
we can import it import it in here so
let's just do after you finished
installing let us do separator and now
we can see that it imports from ui/
separator and then we'll just have
another spacer of -8 so right now we can
see that there this very F line I'm not
sure if you can see on camera but uh
there's a F line of the separator and
then underne the separator here is where
we will uh list all the notes and the
images of course so it's all this list
all right so here is I'm just going to
uh just show here so I'm going to show a
diff with a class name of diff with the
class name of text Center and inside
here inside the diff let's have a H2
that says you have no notes yet so this
H2 will have a class name of text just
Excel text Gray of
500 so if we have no if we have don't
have any notes yet we'll show this so
later on this will have to be uh
conditionally rendered condition
conditionally rendered I spell it right
conditionally okay whatever yeah so
later we'll get the notes and we'll just
conditionally render this okay so we
have set up the simple dashboard and now
I'm going to try to move on to help
setting up the database so that we can
actually start creating notes and
fetching the
nodes right so for the database we'll be
using a neon DB so and we'll be also
using drizzel to interact with this neon
database so come down to Neon dotech
right this is a domain and you might
need to sign up or log in if you have
not done so so you have to sign up into
the the database so by default it
creates gives us a free database to work
with right so you can then create a new
project for like a free free database so
for the name let me just do uh ideation
Das ideation D YouTube then just choose
default postr version and choose a
region that's closest to you in this
case I'm closest to Singapore so I'm
going to put Singapore and then just
leave the rest as default and just
create a project so then this will give
us a database connection string right
then we can copy this in so let me just
copy in this URL right then we can
actually close down the console actually
we don't need that anymore so come down
to your EnV file right and we need the
database URL so let me just do datab
base underscore URL and just paste this
in right so make sure there's no white
space right right and one more thing you
need to add here is at the end right at
the end of this string right I want to
help add this uh question mark SSL mode
equals require so we need this SSL mode
equal required because we're going to be
connecting to our DZ RM and we need to
be secure so we add this here so make
sure you have that added in then now we
can actually start making the drizzle
orm uh to actually interact with this
database so drizzle orm so if you're not
sure this is just a object relational
mapper which allows us to interact with
our SQL databases to very nice
typescript objects okay so how what we
do is first come down and just actually
close this close this tab I'll show you
I walk you show how to actually install
result so come down here and just do mkm
install drizzle dorm right drizzle dorm
come down to your folder okay and we'll
create a new Under lip right so lip is
for Library so basically any any files
that is like any utility files any
folders that we need to prepare to use
beforee put in the lip so create a new
folder under called DB so it's going
going to store our database so inside
here we have two files one is called
index.ts and one is called schema. TS so
this index.ts is going to contain the
drizzle configuration so initialize our
drizzle U drizzle object and the schema.
TS is where we Define our database
schema like all the tables and the
columns so come down to your index.ts
for the table and DB and let us actually
do it start configuration so one more
thing you to install is mpm install at
neon database SL serverless right so
sorry ignore the rest we just need this
at neon database serverless because we
need basically this is a how say is is
to help us connect the neon database to
our result orm so after installing that
let's import a few things so the first
thing we import from the at neon
database serverless is we import the
neon object itself and also the neon
config okay and the other thing is we
need to install import drizzle right
actual drizzle so we import from drizzle
RM import from drizzle rm/ neon d
HTTP okay so let's import the dzo object
here so then now we can do neon config
do fetch connection cache sorry fetch
connection cache equals to true so
basically we just want to cach all the
connection so that it doesn't like
repeat uh creating new con connection
every time we reload the page okay so
then we're going to check if not
process. env. database URL right we got
then throw a new throw a new error
saying that database URL is not defined
so we need this EnV variable that we
have defined in here so if there isn't
this variable it's going to True an
error all right so then lastly we can
just do cons SQL equals to Neon invoke
the neon function and we can invoke it
on the process. env. database URL okay
then lastly we can just export a DB
object which is the drizzle right then
we just passing the SQL uh SQL object
into the drizzle function here so this
DB is how we got interact with the thing
so we can do things like uh db. select
from from
where something like that so this is how
we build the SQL connection strings to
get back results from our database so
now that we have this let's actually
Define the schema so what kind of tables
will we really need it's a really
actually really simple project we only
need in this schema. TS we only need to
Define one table okay so before that
let's import some utility functions to
help us Define the table so be importing
from drizzo
or/ PG dcore so PG is for postgress
postgress core core and we import a few
things like PG table so we need this PG
table to Define our table so let me just
do export cons uh dollar sign
notes okay equals to PG table and then
basically we giving a name of notes so
this notes uh name is going to be what
save between within the post database
this the table name right and then we'll
pass in the configuration object so this
is where we actually pass in all the
columns so first we have ID column it's
going to be a Serial right so we this
serial we imported from PG core right
can see it's Auto imported so with zero
and basically the inside the name right
this is basically the name the column
name within the database right it's
going to make it into a primary key so
then we also have a name field which is
a text field also from PG dcore uh PG PG
core and will give you a internal table
name of name I'll make sure that this is
not
now lastly we have a created uh not
lastly but one more thing is created at
so we have a typ time stamp right will
be time stamp so import this from PG
core Also let's just name it to the same
thing created at do not now so make sure
it's not now and by default we want to
basically default it to now yeah that's
pretty much it so whenever the a new
road gets created this created at fuel
will default to this uh to the current
time span time
stamp then lastly not lastly again sorry
so image URL so this is where we store
the open the D image right the Firebase
image so this will be a text that just
maps to image
URL yeah and then for this we have a
user ID course we want to know which
user created the note right so this is a
one to many relationship so let's do
text is a user ID and make sure this not
now so this user ID will come from the
cler user ID and then lastly we have the
editor state which is just a text of
editor
State yeah that's pretty much it so this
editor state is basically what I start
like whenever we create a new note right
we we save the state of the whatever
state of the content here of what we
have written yeah so like let's say we
come into our cat right so everything
here is saved into the database into
this table called editor State yeah so
now that we have defined this schema
right let's actually one just last line
let's just export a type called notes
type so we might need the types script
type for this PG table right so we can
just do it by doing type of uh dollar
sign notes so these dollar sign notes
come from this PG table and we just do
infer select so if we do that if you
hover over this note type now we can see
the types script type so we can inspect
the name user ID and all the ID so this
is very useful later on when we are
actually doing the uh UI and the
typescript
definitions so let's save that so now
that we have defined the schema how do
we actually make sure that the schema is
synced with the database in the neon DB
Cloud so for that there's one more tool
called uh mpm install uh drizzle Das kit
so let me just uh tell you the
difference what's the difference between
drizzle RM and drizzo dkit so uh drizzo
orm is what we use to interact with the
with to the database right basically
like within our app we can
programmatically in use the drizz RM to
interact and fetch data but drizzle uh
drizzle kit is not uh it's not necessary
but it's a developer tool to basically
help you migrate your changes let's say
you added a new table or you add a new
column you have to make sure that the
column is synced up with the neon
database then you can use DZ kit to
actually inspect like uh push your
migrations up to the database and also
it gives you a studio like a web Studio
to view all your database and all your
rades okay so now that we have installed
DRZ kit let's actually uh create a
configuration object to actually make
sure that uh we know where this
configuration file lives in so come down
to your uh to your file directory again
okay and we have to create a in the root
file like in the root folder everything
outside of the source create a new uh f
file called drizzle. config dots so it
has to be drizzle.
config.yml
the type of config
from drizzo dkit so this config object
will tell us like what kind of
configuration is
needed and now let's actually uh do
export
default right and this object is going
to satisfy the config object so now we
can get some very nice like type
annotation right right here we can do
control space and we can see all the all
the different things we need for this uh
configuration object so for the driver
right we can see we we using postgress
and then for the schema right this
schema is basically telling where where
does the schema F livt in so right now
we can see that it lives in uh relative
to this file it lives in Source slash
Source SL lip ddb schema. TS so let us
do that so we'll do/ Source
/p/ DB schema. TS okay and then lastly
for the DB credentials we pass in the
connection string to be the process.
env. database URL right and make sure
that this exists so one issue you're
going to face is that this is not going
to exist right why because next y thing
right it automat loads in your EnV but
it only loads the EnV file for any file
that's accessing it within the source
directory so any folder that's trying to
access the EnV outside of the source
directory next just does not handle that
so this D.C
config object and we can pass in the
path equals to do EnV so it's just
basically telling this file where the
the the EnV file lives in so that it's
able to Lo load in this database URL for
this uh variable to make sense okay so
now that we have that last thing we need
to do is come down to your TS config.js
and we have to change the target to es6
so just some weird issue within dzo but
you just have to change it to es6 for
this to work so now that you have done
that everything is going to work
perfectly so now you can come back to
your terminal and push your your schema
up to the
database so to do that we do MX drizzle
dkit push PG so colon PG so if you enter
this it's going to rein the schema right
so it's going to see that it's going to
rein the configuration file this drizo
config.txt
a studio right so if you run this
there's going to be one error it's going
to say that actually one we need to
install one more module which is the PG
package right so to actually interact
with the database so we do mpm install
PG postgress so after installing that we
can actually run the MPX studio right d
kit studio and now we can see that is it
will show us all our different tables so
let me just pull this up sorry let me
just pull this up
here okay so now we can see that we have
this notes object notes table so we able
to inspect all our different tables and
right now we can see this notes is ID
name created at image URL user ID and
this all maps correctly to the uh schema
schema that we have defined here so now
we have ensure that the database is set
up and we have pushed our schema up to
the neon database so that's perfect
you're doing
well okay so the next step after setting
up the database is I'm going to
basically create this uh
this basically uh this notes to
basically allow you to add create add a
new notes so the UI to add a new note so
I'm going to show you how to make this a
uh this new notebook so when you click
on it there's a a dialogue a popup that
allows you to enter the name and you can
press create to actually do the back end
call so for now let us just go back to
our dashboard page dashboard page and
then let us actually do put the
dashboard the add component here okay so
let me just see how to actually start
all right so here just below the below
the diff right for the you see this
conditionally rendered you have no notes
just below here this is where we display
all the notes okay so here I'm going to
create a new diff a new diff sorry a new
diff they have a class name of so it's
going to be a display grid so it's going
to have a grid layout so we have let's
do grid then when it's small screen
above we do grid calls D3 then when it's
medium we'll do gr- call-
five then when it's just on a small
screen like on the mobile screen we just
do g c of one and lastly we have gap of
three and then within here is where we
display all the notes but before all the
notes right we actually can add a create
a note
dialog dialog so this is actually what
isown here like this you see this borded
new notebook button here where you can
click to add this to have this popup so
let's create that component so come down
to your folder under components that us
to create sorry not under UI make sure
it's under components okay so let's do
create note dialogue dialog.
TSX do TSR fce okay so for the create
note dialogue let's actually make it
into a cent component use client all
right and then and then and then let
actually let Let's do let's see okay so
to actually make the dialogue we'll be
using the shn dialogue so uh to do that
let's do MP MPX Shen install sorry npx
shnu latest at dialog so this dialogue
is like the popup thing when you click
on the button okay so while it's
installing the dialogue let's actually
do the styling so we won't be returning
the div but be returning a dialogue so
we import the dialog from ui/ dialog and
then within this we have a dialog
trigger trigger so this dialog trigger
is what basically what triggers the
popup right so let us have a div here
sorry div let's have class name of
Border Dash dashed border dashed a
border two border green 600 height of
full rounded of
large okay and then we'll have items
Center just def F Center and on the
small screen we'll have make it Flex uh
column right then when it's hover will
give you a shadow of Xcel and then
transition sorry
transition then on Hover we have a
negative
translat y of one and then Flex row and
padding of four so it's a very long
class name it's very long class name but
let's just do the stying now I'll show
you how it looks like and explain more
to you within the diff here let's have a
a hit to that says new
notesbook let's give you a style name
class name of font semi bolt uh Tex
green
600 there 600 and when it's small give
you a margin top of two and then above
here let's have a plus icon a plus icon
right with the class name of width six
height six Tex green of 600 and and give
a stroke width of three so if you save
it and then let's actually import it so
come back to your dashboard page so me
close it all
out uh dashboard let's actually import
this create note dialogue import and
let's save it and then now we can see
that this uh there this thing that's
showing up here so I think that's a
mistake in my styling right so here uh
items D Center justify the
center okay Flex call
right and the reason why is
because yeah I forget to add a flex so
let me just add a flex
here okay yeah so you need add a flex so
it's just border Das tool and just
basically give you the border and just
align the two uh elements within inside
so when it's small screen you can see
that is uh when it's big screen stack on
top when it's a small screen it's stack
like
horizontally okay that's perfect okay so
then when we click on this right there
that's supposed supposed to be the popup
right so this is the dialog trigger is
what triggers the popup so let's
actually make the popup so we have the
dialog uh content so this dialog Conta
come comes from the/ UI dialogue and
then inside the dialog contenter have a
dialog
header right this dialog header uh
should have let's put in you can create
a new note by clicking the button below
so if we save that and we click on it
now we can see that there's this
dialogue that's popping up right now so
looks very nice okay so let's actually
continue so underneath the dialog header
so wait so within the dialog header this
should actually be wrapped in the dialog
title okay here so the create new note
should be inside the dialog title and
then within it the below the dialog
title we have a dialog um description
okay this dialog description will have
uh we can put like uh you can create a
new note so this should be down here and
the dialog title should have a new
notesbook so let me show you how it
looks like so that it makes more sense
yeah so here new notebook is the title
and then the description is the create
notebook by clicking the button below
okay so that's good and then underneath
the dialogue heer right so this is where
we put our input FS like here we can see
that this is input F
sorry we can see this input
F so you can see there's this input Feld
the for the name and the the buttons to
create or cancel okay so under the
dialogue header we have a normal form
element okay inside the form element let
us uh uh let us just put
a um a spacer with a height of four and
then for this form let give you some
class names of uh sorry not the form the
form doesn't need any So Below uh above
the spacer right below the form right we
have input fi so this input comes from
shat again so let's do MPX shn at UI
latest at input so this is the input
Field St by shn so let's wait for that
to install and then we can imported
input from the/ uiinput and let us
actually give it a placeholder of name
dot do dot so we save it right now we
can see there's a form that has a name f
here okay that's
nice then underneath the spacer right
underneath the spacer let's actually put
the two buttons right so have a flex.
item Center so this where we got put the
two buttons so the first button right
sorry this first button will come from
the this first button will say cancel
and then the second button will
say uh submit uh create here and for the
first button here we have a type of
reset and a variance of secondary okay
and then yeah and then for the create
button right we'll just have a
just put a just save it first so right
now we can see this is create and cancel
here let's give this button down here
styling of VG green
600 all right so it looks more on brand
and for this uh items Center so just
between let's give it a gap of two so
that it's space out a little more okay
that's perfect that's perfect so
basically what we want to to happen is
whenever we uh let's add type of submit
so whenever we submit we want to
actually create a back end right so
let's actually create the state to
actually hold the input element here so
we have already made this a use CL so
then now we can do a create a new state
called input and set input to be a
react. new state okay so then we going
bind it into the input field so let's
have a value of input and on change let
us do e we'll do sets input e. target.
value so we have we make it a control
component so that right now we can just
uh enter and then it just uh it will be
bounded to this input variable here
input state that we can access all right
so uh I think that's it for now for the
front end so now I'm going to try to
show you how to create the back end uh
to actually create a new note whenever
we click on this create
button all right so let's actually
create the back end uh end point to
actually generate the images and the uh
the basically the thumbnail for the
image when we submit this name to the
new notebook so I'm going to clear out
all my tabs and then actually create
come down to app create a new folder
called API and then create a new folder
within it again let's call it um let's
see what do we want to call it let's
just create create
notebook right and then within it we can
create a ro. TS so this root. TS is a
special file right so this root. TS it
will look at the F folder structure and
map to a rest end point so we can
basically this this file will map to/
API SLC creat notes book right so this
is the end point that this file
represents so then we can export a async
function called post right and then this
post will will have uh a request a
standard web API request object where we
can actually get the request body all
right so I'm basically I'm going to do
is I'm going to just take the uh cons
body uh cons body so the request body is
going to be await request. Json all
right so this will convert the request
into Json and we can access the request
body from there okay so then we'll get
out a name from the body name equals to
body right so later on we'll be passing
this new notebook name into this
endpoint here so we get back the name so
before that let me actually check
whether the user is authenticated
because if the user is not authenticated
we don't want them to be creating a new
notebook so let's just get get back the
cons equals to off so this off comes
from click slj is a server side function
that will return us with the uh user ID
here okay okay then we'll check if not
user ID right that means they're not
authenticated some we will just return a
new next response right sorry new next
response that says
unauthorized pass in a status of 401
okay so now let's actually create the
image the D image right so before that
let's actually create a new a new
library so come down to your Source SL
lip within the lip let's create a new
file called open ai. TS so this is going
to hold two functions mainly so the
first function is going to be the first
function is going to be a a a sync it's
going to be basically get image uh
generate image prompt okay so and the
second function is going to be obviously
export async uh this second uh Endo is
going to be for the actual image
Generation by the DI API generate image
Okay so so let me just commment this out
first uh sorry this will be asyn
function and this will be also an asyn
function okay so for this generate image
prompt it's going to take in the the
name the prompt which is a string it's
going to basically take a name like
let's say we put in a name like a math
right so we run a new math notebook what
it's going to do this function is going
to be uh responsible for using the open
AI API to generate a very descriptive
text for the math notebook so it will
generate like
uh oh a a thumbnail a thumbnail that uh
has a bunch of color
colorful numbers and
circles things like that basically it
gives a very nice uh very detailed
description and basically take this
description this uh this prompt this
description and will then feed it into
this general image because for the dly
API the more specific and the more
detailed your description the better the
image result is going to get back so
therefore we need this image prompt
function to actually generate a very
detailed description from a simple name
all right so to do that let's actually
uh configure the open open AI so come
down to your terminal and let's install
the open AI package so open ai- so this
open a-h is a special uh version of open
that allows you to run on the versal H
end point uh versal H run time to make
it faster and there U allows your
function to run for longer okay so yeah
so then let's close out the terminal and
let's uh
initialized open API so we need a few
things import two things from open a-h
so we need uh the first thing is
configuration and the second thing is
the open AI
Epi okay so for the first thing we'll do
is Con config will configur uh
configurate to be new
configuration new configuration and we
pass in the open AI API key so how do we
get the open EI API key so come down to
your browser and just search for open EI
API
key okay come down to the first link
here and then just come down to menu and
then your API so first you need to
obviously register for the open a
account yeah so come down to I think
overview and let's actually get started
for developers and sign up if you have
not already and or sign in if you have
an account okay so after you have uh
sign in to the dashboard I want you to
come down to your personal like this uh
that manual dashboard and then come to
view API
and then here you can then create a new
secret key and you can name it adiation
D YouTube so create the secret key right
then it will create a secret API key for
you and copy the key so after you've
copied the key you can just close it out
we don't need this anymore so come back
here come down to your EnV and let us
call open eore API key and let us just
place the in so there's a secret key so
let's save it and then now come here and
passing the API key to be process. env.
open EI open ei- ai- key so make sure
this matches whatever you have here
spell it correctly so this one spell it
correctly okay so then after this we can
actually initialize the cons open AI
equal to new open AI API passing in the
configuration object so now this open AI
we can call different functions on it
like let's say create check completion
or we can create image here so this
create image is what is going to be used
for the D image gener
okay so then come down here for the
generate image prompt for the generate
image prompt so we take in the name
right so rename it to name so this name
is The Notebook name right so let's
actually create the uh description so
put in the TR catch block and then
basically what we're going to do is we
do cons response equals to await open EI
do create chat compl completion we're
passing the model to be a GPT -3.5
dturbo
and then for the messages we have an
array so the first message will be a
system message basically from the AI to
tell you what what is meaning to do what
it's supposed to do right so we tell you
that uh you are a
creative and helpful AI
assistant assistant capable capable of
generating interesting thumbnail
descriptions for my
notes okay then we tell it that your
output will be fed into the
D
API to generate a thumb
nail okay then we just tell I want uh
the
description should be
minimalistic and flat stop so you can
just basically prompt the different like
and prompt the AI to give whatever you
want so we're just telling it that it's
able to uh output a description of a
interesting thumbnail and then for the
second message here is where we actually
pass in the promt so we have a row of
user and then for the content we can
just say that uh please generate a
thumbnail description for my Note book
titled and Fe the name so this names
come from this parameter which come from
this uh frontend U that will pass back
to the back end later okay then once we
got this response we can just do uh let
us do uh cons data equ goes to await
response. Json so convert the response
to Json then we do cons image
description equals to data do choices
sorry do choices index zero. message.
content all right then last you can just
return the image description as a string
so to tell type script that this
function returns a string and if there
are any errors let's just do console do
uh log error and just return the error
so let's save that okay so actually
instead of return let's actually just
throw the error okay that's cool so
that's good so now we got the image
description so let's actually try this
out so I'm going to come back to my
root. ts and we can actually test out
the image description function that we
just written so let's do cons image
description equals to await General
image promt pass in passing in the name
from the body and for now let's do
console. loock image
description okay and then we just return
a new next
response response that sorry response
that says
Okay okay so I'm going to conso the log
and we're going to try to link it up to
the front end right now okay so for the
front end to actually hit the back end
and point I'll be using a library called
react query so it's just a a library to
manage a client and server State and
actually mutations to the server that
mean like hitting the end points or like
quaring something from the backend API
so to install that we'll just do npm
install at 10 stack right/ react D query
right so this react query will help us
just manage the state within our
application right to hit the end points
to actually mutate mutate and get back
the results so to actually use that
let's come down to our directory come
down to our components and let's
actually create a new component called
providers provider. TSX so let's just to
TSR FC this is going to be a client
component all right so we have this
client providers component it's going to
WP our entire application so we're going
to import a few things so we'll import
uh from at 10stack react query so we'll
import two
things the query client and so the query
client provider so the first step here
is in the props we receive the children
that means it's the application that we
are wrapping around it will be a react
Noe so let's destructure the children
from the props and let's actually just
rep the uh query client
provider uh we'll rep the query client
provider here and then we'll just put
the children here children okay so this
qu client provider requires one thing
requires this client so how do we get
this client we get it by just doing cons
quy clients equal
to it goes to New query
client like this and just have to pass
in the query client
here yeah quy client okay yep that's
pretty much it uh let me just spell this
correctly query client
oops query Cent okay come on okay so let
me just copy this here all right so
basically we just wrap the entire
application in this children so the the
reason why we need this provider is
because let's let's imagine right you
have one page that is fetching a list of
notes so you fetch all the notes from
this one page and you display on the
front end here but let's say you
navigate to another page and you are
fetching the same end point you're
hitting the same end point and getting
back the same notes right instead of
basically uh doing the same request
twice and hitting the end point twice
react query will notice that hey I
actually just fet this query about like
5 seconds ago right I I can just save
the request by just reusing the same
result from the first uh query so
basically it will just store this uh
result in a cache and then it will just
use this cach instead of hitting the end
point again so that's why we need this
query Clan provider such that every
component within our react Tre is able
to have access to this cach so I hope
you understand uh this concept in react
query okay and then we can just come
down to our layout. TSX that wraps our
entire file and we can just uh wrap our
let's wrap our body right with the
provider
provider Provider from our components
wrap this body and let's save it then
now we can use the react
query so let's actually hit the Endo
right so come back to our uh create
notes dialogue here so basically let us
do a let us have a cons handle submit
here so this handle submit uh is going
to have a a type of uh it's going to
have a type of e this e will be a uh
react. form event right it's going to be
HTML form event so it's going to give us
a type annotation uh for what this event
is so the first thing here we going to
do is we'll just do e. prevent default
so we don't want to submit the actual
form right so then we're going to come
down here to this form component here
and just do onsubmit so we're just
passing the handle submit function here
okay that's pretty pretty cool and then
let's actually continue coding out so
what we want to actually had hit the end
point to actually create this remember
this create notebook endpoint so let's
create a mutation for that so cons uh
create
notesbook uh equals
to uh use mutation so this use mutation
a mutation is basically like a a
function that hits an end point okay so
this mutation will take in a mutation
function which is going to be Asing
function uh and we need one more package
to actually hit the end point we'll just
mpm install AOS so AOS is uh just a HTTP
client to actually help us hit the end
point at the back end so we'll just do
uh cons response cons response equals to
await exos poost sorry exos so when you
import
exos uh let's import exos from
ex so ex. post so we'll be hitting the
end point right so be SL API SL
create uh sorry
slash API slash
create notebook so make sure that this
matches whatever you have here right
create notebook right so is uh mapping
to the file this create notebook file
folder I mean okay and then we'll just
return response do data okay so remember
we also need this like uh remember when
we hit this end point we are expecting a
name in the body request body so you
have to pass in this name into the
request body so this name will just be
the input field
so this input is basically what we pass
in we write in this text box here so now
we got this create notebook function
this mutation we can actually call it so
before we call it let's actually check
if input equals to uh empty string let
us just do uh window. alert say please
enter a name for your notes for your
notesbook and then we just
return okay so if the input is not now
then I actually do create note. mutate
so create this create note uh book
function has a mutate uh function on it
where we can just pass in the variables
so in this case we don't have any
variables that need to pass in here so
pass in undefined but then the second
variable is an object that will give us
some callbacks so on success so if it
succeeds we're going to just do
console.log yay uh notes
created then if it fails on error we'll
just uh just do console do error error
so we just log out the error so let's
save it first and let's actually try it
out right now so I'm going to do here is
basically when I just when I by write
when I enter something like a cat and
press create it's going to call this
handle submit function it's going to B
then going to call this mutate function
this mutate is whatever is here this
mutation function so it's going to hit
this endpoint create notebook it's going
to pass in the input as a name it can
return response or data and remember if
you remember just now we are just trying
to lock the image description to make
sure the open AI is working so let me
just open up the terminal here so that
we can see the image description being
locked out if everything works correctly
so I'm going to just press create and
then we can see that it's compiling the
create notebook route and then if
everything works perfectly okay perfect
see now we can see that this image
description so this is the response from
open AI is it will say that oh
minimalistic and flx flat start
thumbnail description playful feline
with cous eyes right
uh yeah so we can see this description
is what we this image description we can
fit this description into the D API
right so let's create continue creating
the backend all right so come back to
your open a
file right so now that we have this
let's actually make the generate image
so this image will have the obviously
the prompt right so this promt comes
from this uh the function up here this
image description so we have image
description which is a string and let
actually call the open a function so
we'll do a TR catch block so we'll do
cons response equals to await open a DOT
uh uh create image passing in the prompt
is the prompt being the image
description we passing Nal one so how
many image you want to generate we want
to generate one image only and will tell
you the size of the image you want to
generate is 256 by 256
pixels yeah 256 by 256 so yeah like this
and then lastly we can just do cons data
equals to await response. Json so want
to convert this response into a Json
format then we can access the image we
can get cons image URL equals to data.
data at index zero right. URL and then
lastly we can just return image URL as a
string then if there's any error let's
just console. error the error so let's
save it and by right this function will
give us back a image URL pertaining to
the image description generated by open
itself so come back to your root. TS so
after we have generated the image
description all right so let's actually
now tra generate the the image so we're
going to first check if not image uh so
if not image description right that mean
something R wrong so I'm going to just
return a new next response response
saying that uh fil to generate image
description as in in a status of 500 all
right then if so if there's image
description let's actually generate the
image so we do count image URL equals to
await generate image here so we get it
from the open AI uh passing the image
description so now this image URL will
hopefully return us with the image URL
that's
generated then we'll check if not image
URL that means something R wrong so I'm
going to copy this
here and we'll just say that failed to
generate image
let's save it all
right then Lastly lastly let's actually
create the new notes okay so uh con
notes equals to await DB so we're going
to try to insert a new note within the
table create a new row so this DB
remember we import it from at lip DB so
this is the if you come back to your lip
DB file this drizz RM this DB is what we
accessing so you can call AWA DB do
inserts into the dollar sign notes which
is from the schema
dot uh values so want to insert insert
the name so if you press control space
you're able to see the different
attributes that we need to pass in to
create the rle so the name will
obviously be uh the name that comes from
this request body so we can just
short-and it and then for the user ID
right we get it from this user ID up
here and then lastly we need the image
URL which is from this image URL from
this open AI here okay effect and then
we want to return the new inserted node
ID right so like which what's the new
create newly created ID so we can do
returning uh what what do we want to
return you want to return the inserted
ID to be uh dollar sign notes.
ID and then finally we can access it by
doing here we can just do notes IDs
right and then we can just return a next
response uh return a next response
Json passing in the want to want to
return the new ID that's has been
created right so just do notes IDs at
index zero. insert. ID so because this
uh insert statement is going to return
us with an array of with a list of all
the inserted statements but because we
only inserted one so we going access the
first one and we access this inserted ID
which comes from this returning
statement here so then finally this no
ID will give us back to the inserted
newly inserted uh row row ID okay so
that's pretty much it so let's save it
and let's actually try it out so come
back to your create note dialogue so we
can see that it's on success right if we
succeed right we know that it's going to
return us with this object with this
attribute called note ID so let's
actually destructure this notes ID and
then we can just console.log a notes ID
so I can say that uh created new
note okay so let's actually try out so
I'm going to open up the console
here and save it so we going to hit the
end point right it's going to hit the
endpoint then it's going to call the
it's going to call the image URL it's
going to generate the image and then you
going to create a new R the database and
return us with the note ID which will
then console. log out here if it
succeeds so let's actually try that so
press create so right now it's hitting
the end point although you can't see it
so you can see that it's trying to hit
the end point so let's wait for 8 to 10
seconds and hopefully y hopefully it
will create a new row and console to
lock out the newly created ID all right
so perfect it works so here in the
console you can see that it says created
new note with this object of note ID so
let's actually inspect this note okay so
come down here so let's come down to the
new Prisma not Prisma Studio sorry the
drizzle Studio we do MPX drizzle kit
Studio let's inspect the note that we
have created here okay here so you can
see that there's a new note with ID of
one that name is Cat created now and
have a new image URL so this new image
URL is the open AI dly image so let me
copy this and let me just inspect it on
the URL so we can see okay so that is a
cute very very nice minimalistic cat
image that's been generated for our
notebook so now that we know that it
works so that's really really good okay
so let's close this down and uh now we
can move on so let me just close this
visual studio and exit it
out all right perfect perfect perfect so
if it successfully generated it we going
to then redirect them to a new page uh
we got directly redirect them to like
the uh to this page for the uh note ID
for them to actually edit their new
notebook okay so here we're going to
redirect them to this page so here on
success let's actually redirect them so
we'll just get the router so cons router
equals to use router so this use router
comes from not NEX router but
from sorry import from Nex SL
navigation here is use
router okay so invoke this and we get
the router object so if it succeeds
right we can just do router. push
slote book slash note ID like this okay
perfect yeah then that's pretty much it
yes yes yes okay so then if there's an
error let me just uh do window.
alert uh fil to create a new notebook
okay so let me actually try it out let
me just try it out so uh one more thing
to add is when we come down to this
button when it's loading when it's
creating we actually want to disable the
button right for a nicer user experience
so for this button we'll just do disable
so we disabled it when the create
notebook is is loading so this create
notebook has a attribute called is
loading to tell whatever the request is
still loading and then we'll have a
loader so if create notebook do is
loading right so if it's loading let's
display a loader so we'll have Loader 2
from lucd D react we'll give you a class
name of with of four height of four
margin R of two and animate spin so
let's save it so let's actually create a
new notebook now so click on here and
let us create a a doc notebook so when I
press create you can see this is loading
to indicate that's a that is actually
doing the API call and then if
everything works it's going to Jetpack
the note ID and it will redirect us to
uh sorry it's going to redirect us to
this/ notebook note ID that we got back
from the new uh created Ro so let wait
for a while and then if everything goes
well and yep that's perfect so now we
can see that it redirects us to/
notebook SL2 so this is the ID yeah okay
so that is excellent that's excellent we
have created a new notebook we can
create a new r and we have generated the
image for the
thumbnail okay so now that we have
redirected this notebook page let's
actually start working on the notebook
page okay so come on to your app
directory let's create a new uh folder
called notebook right cuz this is trying
to correspond to notebook right and then
inside the notebook folder let's create
another folder called angle brackets
notes ID right and then within this
folder let's create a page. TSX so this
uh angle brackets is a wild card it's a
wild card to access this like uh ID
variable here so let's do TS r f
c right to get the react uh react
component and just let's do notebook
page all right so we got the notebook
page how do we actually get the notes ID
from the URL though so uh next J
actually provides us with the with the
note ID in the props itself so within
the props you can access the perms
object within the perms do have a note
ID which is a which is a string so this
note ID is going to correspond to like
whatever you have put in the angle
brackets not not angle brackets square
brackets so then we can destructure the
perms and we can destructure the note ID
within the perms so for now actually
just display the note ID to make sure
that everything is working so in this
case yeah it's showing the two the two
is showing which represents the notebook
SL2 here okay so now that we got the no
ID let's actually retrieve it right so
I'm going to make this into a server
component so we can fetch it directly in
the component so this component is going
to run once in the server it's going to
fetch the database for the ID and going
to return the HTML to the client so
let's do let's actually check if the
users authenticated here first so cons
user ID equals to awaits off so this off
comes from cler nextjs and then now we
can just do um let's do cons notes
equals to await uh sorry await U DB so
the database from dzo do select from the
dollar sign
notes where equals right with can just
put it in the sense right so actually
there'll be an end Clause right so end
so there'll be two Clause the first is
the notes the dollar sign. notes. ID has
to equal to par in notes ID and the uh
dollar sign notes. user ID should equals
to the user ID here so this will be this
will be also yeah so let's see the
reason why because this not user ID
might not exist so if not user ID right
so if it's unauthentic unauthenticated
let's just return um uh return
redirect from next SL navigator to
slash dashboard so let's save it so
basically what we did here is we get the
user ID right if there's no user that
means they're not loog in we got to kick
them back to the dashboard right if they
are if they're in we're going to try to
get all their notes right so the note
will be where the ID the note ID equals
to the PM's note ID the URL perm well
and also the user the user ID of that
note must match the user ID that's lock
in CU we don't want uh other people to
view your notes right so we have this
end clause and then this notes will have
just check we're going to check if not
notes do length equals to one so
basically if if notes length not equals
to one that means if there's not exactly
one note that means uh we didn't find
the proper note then we going to just do
return re
direct to/ dashbo so if we have found a
note we are ensure that the note will
leave in notes index zero all right so
now they got this note and I can
actually display it by doing just
putting in here so let just do like
this this on the stringify notes now and
two and now we can see that here it
shows we able to see the ID the name the
Creator at image okay so that's good
that's good so now let's actually build
out the UI for the for this note page
here so instead of returning the Json
let us actually just return a diff this
diff will have a class name of mean
height of screen greeny ping of eight Y
and then here we'll have another diff
with a class name of Max width of 4 XL
and margin X of AO within this uh second
diff we have a link here this link comes
from next SL link here let's actually
just link it back
to/
dashboard all right uh yeah so actually
I'm sorry above this link wrapping this
link that's actually another diff that
wraps this link so this diff is going to
be what is going to be wrapping like
this back button my name and the delete
button here okay so obviously because
you want to put it in a row let's
actually give it a flex right so let's
actually not do that first let's do
bother
Shadow XL border Dash Stone DH 200
rounded large padding of four flx and
items sorry flex and items of Center so
this is rounded here so let me save that
first and now we can see that it shows
up here okay that's good so then this
link here let's actually show the button
to go back so we have a
button that says uh
back so like give you a class name of uh
BG green 600 and a a variance of small
SM yeah so this is size of small okay so
now we got this back button here all
right that is perfect that's perfect uh
one more thing Let me see what is the
issue here uh okay yeah let me just
refresh the page here okay so beside
this a button beside this link right I
also have the link let us have the the
user's name right we have to display the
name and basically which notebook they
on so to get the name of the user we
need one more package which is the uh
mpm install uh at cl/ backend so this
cl/ backend will give us some backend
utilities to get the user from the
actual user ID okay so let me just uh
get the CL user right so come back come
down to your lip folder
and let's create a f f just called click
server. TS so this only runs on the
server right so this click Das server.
CS will import from at cl/ backend we
import the actual CL object and we can
just is just one line export a new cons
CL CLI it goes to
cler right passing in the API key uh
sorry so for this API key we pass in
process. env. C API key so if you come
back Tov file we can see there's this CL
secret key so copy this secret key and
actually paste it here so we are trying
to access this secret key so just save
it and now we got this clck instance
that we can use so come back to the
page. TSX here we can actually get the
cons
user equals to cler uh sorry cons user
equals to cler so this cler comes from
our cler server do users. get user
passing in the user ID so then this will
contain like uh all the stuff like uh
this will awaited so we get back like
the first name and the last name all
right so let us actually put it in the
the UI itself okay so uh underneath here
this uh this link underneath this link
let's actually have another spacer that
just put w-3 so it's just a width of
three just a empty diff and we have a
span this span will have a class name of
font semi board and then inside this bam
will have user. first name and then
user. last name so if we save it here we
can see that my name shows up here right
so it's my first name combined with my
last name here okay that's good so then
lastly for this underneath here let us
have a uh span and we have a class name
of inline block with margin X of one and
we just have a slash and after this ban
after this ban we have another span that
have a class name of text- stone- 500
font semi B and here we'll put the
notes. name okay so now we can see
there's a nice flash slash here followed
by the name of the notes so this is uh
this combination of these three spans
here okay all right so then basically
after this pen we'll have a delete
button here okay so we'll do the delete
button uh later on but just know that uh
the delete button will go here so let me
just put uh ml AO and we'll put a delete
button to do here so we can see that we
put a margin left of Auto so that this
gets pushed all the way to the left to
the right side here so later implement
this this delete button okay that's good
then finally finally finally underneath
uh this underneath this diff so
underneath the we can collapse the
Border here here and then we'll just do
underne so above the two closing diff we
have a another diff of height four so
it's a empty spacer diff a spacer diff
of height D4 and then underneath here is
where we're going to put our editor so
here is going to where our editor goes
so this editor is going to be this thing
that you see here that has all the
functionalities built in so that's the
main part of the application so for now
I'm going to build a a container around
it right so I have a diff here and this
diff is going to wrap this editor later
on let's give you a class name of Border
Stone of 200 Shadow XL uh border rounded
large padding X of 16 padding uh y of
eight and then lastly width of four so
let's save it and right now here is
where our editor will go yeah so you're
doing great so now the next part is
going to be actually configuring the
editor and I'll show you how to actually
build out this very customized editor
from
scratch okay so now let's actually begin
building the editor component which is
the main BL of this project so be using
a editor uh Library called tip tab
editor so it's a it basically giv you a
lot of functionality for building a very
customized and full fles editor
application so let me walk you through
how you do that so so come down to your
app and let's actually under our
components let's create a new component
and let's just call it Tip Tap editor.
TSX so let's do tsrf c okay so we need a
few dependencies for this tip tab so the
first thing we need is um M install
sorry at tip
t/ react then we need tip t/ PM so this
is PM stand for proos mirror so proos
mirror is a primitive which tipt is
built on so we need that for certain
apis and
functionalities and last thing we need
tip t/ uh stter starter kit so this
starter kit will give us a certain
default configuration for like text or
like paragraph or headings for us to
start playing around with so we need
these three things so we'll wait for the
mkm install to be finished all right so
uh my mistake here here it should be tip
tab not tip tab so make sure you spell
it right so then we going wait for the
mpm to
install Okay so once it install let's
come to this editor the first thing is
let's actually make it into a client
component because of using state so uh
I'm going to just configure the editor
so what we going to do is here is we
need something called use editor so
let's import the use use editor Hook
from the tip tab so import from at tip
t/ react and we will need the
a use
editor okay so let's come down here and
let's actually initialize the editor so
we'll take the cons editor equals to use
editor we're passing several things so
the first thing is autofocus to be true
so whenever the page loads we want it to
automatically focus on the text box so
it's a good user experience and then
we'll have a extensions so these
extensions are the remember the starter
kit we install so we need the starter
kit so let's import uh starter starter
kit from at tip t/ starter kit yeah that
we're passing the starter kit into the
uh extensions array and then uh lastly
we have a Content so this is a is a what
is actual content that's going to be
displayed in the editor so we'll bind it
to a state called uh editor State and
we'll do set editor State equals to be a
it's going to be a string okay so then
the content here is going to just be the
editor State all right
so then uh lastly on update so whenever
whenever we change the like we make a
change in the editor right we're going
to just call this function it's going to
do set editor state to be editor. get
HTML so we can see there's a lot of APs
I get Json and things like that right so
you can read all of this in the
documentation I spent about a few hours
reading to the documentation so just
dist it down to the most essential
things that if you're interested in
exploring further and expanding on this
editor then of course you can read the
document ation but anyways this editor
basically allow allows us to use this
method to get back the HTML which will
then bind it to the state this internal
local state okay then lastly for the the
UI let's actually return a a diff this
diff is going to have a uh have a in
another diff call just for the editor
content so this editor content we can
import from tip t/ react and we just
have to pass in the editor to be the
editor instance that we have
instantiated inst
here so let's save it and let's actually
import the tip tab editor here so let's
just do tip tab editor and let's see if
it works so I'm going to just refresh
the page and let's see if everything
works okay and it's good it's working so
now we got this editor and we can like
it's a multi-line thing yeah so you can
see that tiip tab actually comes with
like a very it's quite basic for now
right but I'm going to teach you how to
customize it so I guess the first step
here is actually to uh remove this
outline border cuz it looks very very
annoying doesn't look nice so if you
inspect in here we can see that there's
this uh this class name that's wrapping
everything called the uh tip tab proos
mirror class so we're going to Target
the class in our CSS file and remove the
outline for now so come down to your
global. CSS scroll all the way down here
and we going to add a custom stying to
the tip tab uh tip tab do Pros mirror
Pros mirror class so we're just going to
remove the outline that's all that need
to do and if you come back here right
now we can see that uh there's no longer
a outline here and it looks much cleaner
in my in this case all right so that's
good that's good so let's actually
continue uh defining it so uh let's see
what I want to add here so let me now
teach you how to add this like a det bar
so like you see if you scroll up here
like this and you press Bol uh if you
press Bol you can actually bold it
yeah so I'm not sure why you can bold it
in this case b yeah you can see that if
I press uh command B it BS it or I can
command you to like underline it and
stuff like that so I'm going to teach
you how to get make this editor work all
right so uh come down to here let's
actually create a new menu bar so this
menu bar will be a separate component
that's going to leave on top of the
editor so uh come down to your
components actually create a tip uh Tap
menu
bar TSX we do TSR
fce okay so for this menu bar we will
need to accept the editor so remember
this editor that we have defined uh in
the tip T editor here so this editor we
need to pass into this uh menu bar later
on so let's actually just import the uh
menu bar into the editor first so I'm
going to come up here and just for this
outo diff let's give you a class name of
a flex uh yes a flex and then underneath
here let us just do a uh sorry actually
this should be a react fragment I'm
sorry uh cuz I was thinking of something
else uh let's move this react fragment
down and then move this diff content
down here so I'm going to explain what
this is so this Flex is going to contain
uh the you see this menu bar is one
component and this save button is
another component so we have the tip T
editor menu bar as well as a
button uh that says saved okay so then
it's going to be then uh it's going to
line up side by side and then inside
this edited content here we add more
content down here so it's just minus
stying thing so we're going to pass in
the editor right it's going to pass in
the editor from here so I want to make
sure this editor exist first so we'll do
if editor exists then I'll put the T the
menu bar here so let's actually
configure the props to get it in so let
me just uh put the tip tab here so in
the props we expect the editor to be a
editor from tip t/ react then now we can
uh destructure it from here okay so now
the menu bar is showing up here and we
can continue on okay perfect so for the
menu bar I'm going to just do uh let's
see uh I'm going to return a diff right
this diff is going to have a class name
of flex Flex D rep and gap of two so
this diff is just basically contain all
of these buttons so all these buttons
are differently sty like uh it's a
custom buttons like each button like uh
an individual button so then we got to
just wrap it into all this Flex con a
flex container
so let me just demonstrate some uh some
let me demonstrate something about the
how I say the tip T menu bar so we have
a just a normal button here so this is
not from Shen because we want to style
it a certain way first so for this
button let's have a
uh Bol so we import this Bol uh icon
from Lucy D react let's give you a class
name of width of six and height of
six so let's save it and right now we
can see that this is both icon here as a
button okay so uh so so so so so for
this button we'll pass in a few things
so on click right so let me explain how
this works so we're going to do editor.
chain so this chain is basically saying
that the editor we can chain a lot of
commands on it so the first thing here
we want to do is we want to focus back
on the editor so after we focus on the
editor we want to toggle both so we can
toggle whatever selection we have it on
right now so imagine I have this
selected here and I press this B button
it's going to focus on the editor and
they toggle toggle board on the
selection here okay so after toggle uh
toggling the bo we can actually run the
command here so I just basically found
this API from their documentation I'm
just briefly explaining it here to you
so just need to know about how it works
like this and then for here we want to
disable this button right we will
disable it when edit when the not editor
do can. chin. Focus
tole sorry
tole run sorry here do uh run okay so
what it does is we want to disable it if
the editor cannot toggle B so in some
cases like it just doesn't it's not able
to tole it B then we just want to
disable this button here so you can see
that this is command this this can uh
can function here okay and then we'll
have a class name of we got to check
Okay so if editor sorry we're going to
check uh for a
condition so if editor dot is active so
if it's already bought right we want to
show an active class right so we're
going to show a is active right
otherwise we're going to show empty
class
name okay so right now we can actually
see in acity so if you come down to this
thing it's right now it's invisible so I
can type a few things and I I highlight
this right highlight this button I press
on this button and we can see that it's
B up right so why does is is it just
change the thing it focus on the editor
and it toggles the B so right now we can
we have like this b b functionality
working at it so all we need now to do
is we have to fill in the rest of these
functionalities for like the iism and
the hings and stuff like that so let me
just run through it uh really quickly
I'll run through the first field then
I'm going to copy in the rest so that we
can have better understanding okay so
underneath this button let's actually do
the do the next part so we have another
button so you know actually I can just
copy this button down here and right
instead of tole both this to
tole italics italic and then here will
be toggle italic here and then here be
instead of checking for B we want to
check for
italic here
italic all right then for this instead
of this B icon I'm going to just put it
as italic icon italic icon from Lu DH
react so if we save it right now we can
see that there's not italic thing so if
we highlight this and we can italicize
it yeah so the rest of the concept is
going to be very very similar so what
I'm going to do is instead of wasting
your time and just doing the same thing
over and over again I'm going to just
copy in this uh copy in the code here
from my code up here and let me just
clean up a few things and explain what
I've just did so Tip Tap
menu okay so basically it was the same
thing right I'm receiving the editor
right then I'm basically returning the
buttons that buttons like the Bol
buttons and things like that right
except that I just went through the
documentation I found everything that is
available to us so we have this itze
button we got this strike true button
for the toggle strike toggle code so we
can like toggle it whether we want to
make it a code block or not okay then we
have Hing so the all the Hing level one
to five to six so can have like a
different hings but right now let me
show you why it's not working because
even though I toggled the hings right we
can see the text but the text size stays
the same even though right even though
it's H3 right let me show you if I
toggle it H1 H2 H3 right the thing is
being toggled is being changed but the
Tex SI is not changing this is a
Tailwind issue so we actually need to
install a Tailwind a Pros utility so
this tailn typography allows us to uh
give back the markdown the in terms of
like the H1 it will allow ta to respect
our H1 H2 H3 sizing so to install this
let's actually install the typography
extension right so come down to your
terminal and just do mpm install at TN
CSS typography and then underneath here
come back to your TN config file okay
and we we need to add this typography
into our plugin so scroll all the way
down here for this plugin we add one
more thing called the the require which
is the typography library that we just
install this extension so after we have
this we can come down to our uh tip tab
editor right remember this div that's
wrapping it let give you a class name of
of Pros so now this Pros will allow us
to like uh respect the H1 and H2S so if
we save the pros now and we wrap it now
we can see that now it respects the H1
H2 H3 H4 and H6 yeah so that is
basically what the pros of ta win
utility does for us yes so coming back
here so it's just a different heading
levels things like that then we have
obviously the bullet list for the like
you want to make a list of something you
can do that here you can have order list
code blocks block Cotes and and undo and
redo basically so this supports undo
like I can press contrl Z to undo yeah
so I hope you understand this it's quite
simple API once you understand how to
use it then all this list order is show
basically icons that I found from Lucid
D react so yeah there's not much nothing
too complicated about it yeah so one
more thing here is right right now we
can see that when we when we click on it
when we click on the button right it
when though it's active if is active we
don't have a way of showing whether it's
active so come down to your global. CSS
file okay we can do do is active right
we give a background color of let's say
# da d a DA and have a border radius of
two pixel so if we save it right now we
should able to see it in action right we
can see that when we B it right there's
a background to it I tell the size we
can see there's a nice background to
integrate which which modes are uh which
modes are basically active here so this
H4 H3 H5 yeah so that's pretty much very
simple styling so these all uh read from
the documentation so you don't have to
worry about me too much if you're
interested you can always read more into
into it yeah so I'm just here to like
save you some time and show you the
basics of how to actually get started
with this a powerful editor uh
Library okay so now that we have uh the
editor up and working so now let's
actually work on uh doing the saving
functionality so the auto save so um
every time you type right so we're going
to have a debounce so after the debounce
we're going to basically save it to a
database so if you're not sure what
debounce is I'm going to show you in a
while so don't worry about it so I guess
the first step here is actually let's
close off the menu bar and let's come up
here and let's actually have a u react.
use effect and let's actually just toggo
it on every time the editor State
changes okay so let's just do
console.log editor state
okay so let us actually see what the
editor is going to look like so every
time I I click on it we can see that the
paragraph is form and if I have a
heading right we can see there's a h one
and the paragraph right so let me just
move myself out the way so we can see
how the how the editor looks like so
basically want to save this piece of
information to the database and then
every time we look into our notes uh
this note page we're going to just uh so
that we can load it in and display
whatever we have in the database okay so
to do that so let's actually do the
debounce so the thing is the reason why
we want to debounce it is basically
imagine we are typing in every time
right so we can see that I'm typing in
like let's say uh a few tens of tens of
like let's I'm typing in like maybe 20
or like 30 characters per second okay 20
or 30 characters per second like let's
say I'm typing fast right we do not want
to basically hit the database endpoint
and and try to save the save the whole
text every time we type a character it's
going to be very wasteful of resources
right it's also going to be very like uh
slow right cuz you're hitting the
database like imagine 20 times a second
that's not very optimal so what
debouncing is is debounce is basically
it will just uh wait for a while after
you have finished typing then you wait
for maybe like 500 millisecs to make
sure you have finished typing then it
will trigger the save right so that's
what debounce means so to Rite the
debounce function let's actually come
down to lip and let's write a use
debounce hook. TS okay so it's a custom
hook for us to implement the debound
functionality okay so I'm going to just
import uh react from react we're going
to be using use State and let's export a
function called uh use debounce okay so
this debounce is going to take in two
things going take in the value which is
going to be a string and the delay which
is a number so this value is basically
what is we passing the editor State and
this delay is basically how many
milliseconds do we want to wait after I
finish typing to trigger the save okay
so the first thing we going to do is
going to take cons uh debounce value and
set debounce value it's going to be a
state right passing the initial value
here okay and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to have a react do do do
use
effect uh here and I'm going to just do
con Handler equals to set time
out okay and basically what want to do
is set the bounce value to be the value
every time time the value changes okay
so I'm going to set a time out for let's
say delay seconds delay seconds okay I'm
going to put the delay in here also and
then I'm going to return a uh clean up
function to clear a timeout so let me
explain what I'm going to do doing first
after I call it out I'm going to return
debound value debound value okay so
what's happening here is okay let's see
this value right it changes every 20
characters per second right it changes
20 times per second what it's going to
do is every time it changes right it's
going to call this it's going to call
this use effect is going to be called
okay so when it calls it's going to try
to set the debounce value to the change
value right but it's going to change it
it's going to only set it after let's
say 500 milliseconds right but if I
change it again within 500 milliseconds
it's going to call this function a
cleanup function to clear the timeout so
it never actually gets set so basically
what what it happens is only if I stop
typing after 500 milliseconds then does
this debounce value this function gets C
and then my debounce value will be set
so let me show you in actions to have to
show you then it's going to be much
easier to understand so here I'm going
to have a uh cons
debound State uh debounce at deter State
equal to use debounce we can pass in the
editor State and pass in a uh delay off
let's say 300 seconds would that be
enough actually let's just do 500
milliseconds 500 milliseconds so now I'm
going to try to conso to lock out the
debounce editor state every time it
changes okay so let's try it again right
so now let's I type look as I type you
see nothing gets locked out but watch as
I if I stop typing and after 500
milliseconds see it gets locked out so I
can keep typing and if I stop for 500
milliseconds it gets CAU it gets caught
again so that's what the debounce this
so we can basically like type and then
we can type and only if you stop typing
then will the function be called and
then we can call we can call the save
function here so here we can then save
to D B okay so I hope you understand the
debound thing so now let's actually
write the function the API end point to
actually uh do the saving so come down
to your uh folder and let's under our
API let's create a new folder called
save
not within this folder let's do a root.
TS and let's do export a Asing
function called post and the request
will be a standard request object okay
here all right and then here we can
actually do the uh function to actually
save the
note so the first thing here is let me
just wrap it in a try catch block and
we'll just destructure we'll get the
body out of AIT request. Json so get the
request body so uh within the request
body I will need two things right we
will need uh the sorry we need the sorry
let me see we need the notes ID and the
editor
state so this editor state will be what
is shown here this uh debounce console
loock and then this note ID is basically
we are trying to see which note which
note are we actually trying to update
okay so we need to this we need T this
so we need these two pieces of
information so we got to just check if
not editor state or not note ID so if
neither of these are if one of these are
not passed in we want to return a new
new uh new next GS new sorry next
response right passing in uh Missing
edit State on no ID in a state of 400
okay so if there's there's a note ID
we'll just set the uh note ID equals to
pass in notes ID so let's actually
change this to a let so that we can
reassign it here okay
awesome so now let's actually get the
notes right so cons notes we're going to
try to find the note with that note ID
so we do await DB dot
select from dollar sign notes from the
schema sorry here
from notes dollar sign from the schema
right where right where uh the notes. ID
equals to the note ID pass in from the
request body so if notes do length not
equals to one so if that means there's
not exactly one note that means
something went wrong so let's just
return a new next response saying that
uh failed to update passing the status
of
okay so now that we got the note let
actually get the note equals to notes
index zero so it's the first notes out
of this
array okay then now let's actually check
okay so uh let's just
do uh if notes but editor State not
equals to editor state so this is the
Old State right this is whatever is in
the database and this is the new state
so we can check if is different because
if it's the same then it doesn't make
sense updating it we're just wasting
resources so only if it's different then
let's actually set set right so let's
just do await db.
update uh update notes we want to set
the editor state to be the new editor
state that we got up here right where uh
where the note ID equals to the note ID
pass in from the body yeah so I hope you
understand it's just we're just updating
the editor State based on the Note ID
and then if everything goes well let's
return a next response do uh Json saying
that success equals to true and a status
of 200 if there's any errors let's
actually console do out console. error
the error and let's return a new next
responsejson right asking the success
success to be false and the status
of sorry St sorry this is
response let passing a status of
500 internal server
error okay so now we got this Point
Let's actually try using it on the front
end so remember you want to save to DB
every time the debounce editor State
changes right so let's actually do that
so first let's actually get the mutation
function so cons save notes equals to
use mutation from uh 10 St query passing
the mutation function to be an async
function to hit the end point so we want
to hit this a safe not end point here so
let's just do cons response equals to
await exos
host SL API saave note so this is what
is uh What uh end point we have just
written here then we need to pass in two
things right we need to pass in the
notes ID which is uh the notes so how do
we actually get access to this note we
can actually get it from the notes uh
you can get it from the notes which is a
notes type so remember this note type we
got it from our our schema here right so
we can actually get this notes type here
and can destructure the
notes
and let actually passing the note ID to
be note ID and then of course we want to
have the editor state to be whatever we
have this editor State here so this note
ID and this editor state will be passed
back into this function no ID and editor
State and then we do the corresponding
update so we actually need to pass in
this notes right if not we do have
access to this notes so come down to
your uh notes ID page for this tip tip
tab editor TP script is yelling at us
because we need the notes we need to
pass in this notes object that we've got
fetch from the database so now we have
this we got access to the note we can
have access to the note ID and stuff
like that then let's just return
response.
data okay pretty cool pretty cool so now
we got this function to actually update
the update the database so let me just
do if we could just check if the bounce
editor State equals to an empty string
let's just return course it doesn't make
sense if you want to like uh update an
empty string so if not let's actually
just save note mutate so call the mutate
function which will in turn call this uh
in hit this end point okay so we'll do
mutate uh passing in undefined so course
we're not passing in anything to this
like to this function here right and
then on the second argument here we can
just do on success so if there's a
success let's actually console. loock
success update and let's passing
Thea
then uh on error so if there's an error
that's console do error error and let's
just do yeah that's pretty much it okay
so then let's actually have a saving
State also so right now we can see
there's this save button so we can see
that in a deploy app when it save is a
save disable save and then as we like
type around we can see that it changes
to a saving state so we can actually do
that here by creating a new local
state so let's have another state called
cons is
saving and we do set is saving uh
actually we don't need a local state we
can just use this save note
function so underneath this button here
right so this button here we can
actually put uh here so we do uh save
notes dot is loading so if it's Saving
right I'm going to do saving if not I'm
just put saved and that's actually this
able this button and give you a variant
of
outline so right now it will be safe and
then basically when I hit end point so
let's actually try out okay so I'm going
to open the console I'm going to start
typing so it's going to hit the endpoint
right then you can see that it it flash
for a second and it successfully updated
that means our database has been updated
and we written with a success of true so
that's good so now we can see that as we
type and stuff it will hit the end point
and it will save it I can bold it if I
bold it it will also trigger the save
so let me just remove this console lock
cuz it's getting kind of annoying so let
me just remove this and yeah everything
is working perfectly so we're a to save
it so let me just right now if I refresh
the page right we can see that uh if I
refresh the page right now nothing
appears right so we need to load in the
the Save Editor State on initial render
so what we can do here is come down here
to this remember here this we have this
uh editor State instead of setting to MD
string we going set it to the note.
editor State yeah and then yeah so if
there's no editor State we can just set
it to empty string yeah so in the case
that uh en state is now right we'll set
it empty string if not you can see that
it's showing up here so I can like type
like Hello World right so we can see
that it's saved if I refresh the page
right it saved to the database okay
that's perfect so uh we have learned how
to use a debounce hook to debounce our
change and then once the debounce has
been triggered we I've taught you how to
actually hit the endpoint to save the
editor state within the database so
you're doing amazing then the next St
we're going to teach you how to
integrate the the AI into the chat
completion all right so just one thing I
want to change is if there's no editor
state that means like it's a new Fresh
notebook right so instead of putting MD
string I'm going to put a h one that
that basically has the notes notes name
in it so that it's like a better user
experience so I'm just going Toc
capsulate the notes. name and just put
in the H1 tag all right so this a very
simple UI fix all right so let's
actually now start working on the AI
completion part so in here in the
original app you can see that when I
press on let's say control I press shift
a right when I press shift a it
activates the AI and then it will just
uh help me aut to complete all this
stuff right uh and to do that we
actually need to bind a custom key bind
like a custom keyboard shortcut so that
when we press shift a it's able to
detect that we want to start Auto
completing so to actually do the custom
custom keyboard we actually need to
create a new custom text so right now we
can see there this u in the use editor
we got this extensions on this start kit
right so we're going to add another
custom extension uh and this custom
extension will contain the keyboard
shortcut so to get that we need to
import one thing from up here which
which is uh import from uh let me see
where is it from okay at tip
tab tip tab SL extens text extension
extension SL text uh all right and we
need import the sorry uh the text so
just default import so we can pass this
text into the extensions here right but
we want we want to customize it a little
so let's actually do this we're going to
do a cons custom text okay custom text
equals to text do extend so we're going
to extend this text I want to pass in
the add keyboard
shortcuts okay this add keyboard
shortcut will be a function and what it
returns is a it will return a a keyboard
sh cut and then a function that will be
CAU whenever the keyboard shortcut is uh
triggered so in this case you want to be
CAU whenever we have a shift a so when
we press shift a we can to call this
function and I'm going to do is just
going just return true for now I'm going
to say control. l activate EI okay and
passing this custom text into the
extensions list custom text and that's
save it so now let's see if it works so
I'm going to come open up this editor
and the console so by right if I press
shift a
right I press shift a we can see that uh
let's see if it works okay uh
shift- a let's see if it works press
shift a ah okay it works now so you see
activate AI is being called so when we
press shift a we can see that the
activate AI function is being call so
that's good so now here we know that
within this function is where we can
call the auto complete right so for the
AI part we could be using a a versel AI
SDK so it's a pretty new uh um package
from versel right that give us a very
nice library to interact with backend
LMS and also give us that very nice a
streaming effect so you see when we
press like shift a right here there like
the text will slowly come in one by one
so we have to do that using the
streaming effect so verel SDK give us
that opportunity so let's actually set
up the back end first for the completion
so come down to your / API come down to
your app folder come down to your API
folder let's create a folder called
complete
with this completion let's do root. TS
so this root. TS will map to a/ API
completion so this file here will map to
this uh will map to this URL so let's
export a async uh function called host
which will get in the request which a
request object so let's actually import
install the E from Vel so is mpm install
AI so just two characters AI this will
give us a lot of power in the completion
so I'm going to close this down and
we're going to import a few things from
uh verel so the first thing is let's
import the uh import from open EI H so
it's the same configuration we did just
now so we need the open EI API as well
as the configuration object and now we
want to import uh a few things import
from AI so this AI is what is what we
just installed so uh let's actually in
uh initialize the opening a first so
let's do config to new configuration
passing in the API key to be process.
env. open AI API key which is what we
have from the EnV file here okay and
then let's actually initialize the cons
open AI equals to new open a API passing
in the configuration object so now we
can actually play around with this openi
object so the first thing here is
actually let's uh extract the prompt
from the body so to that we'll do cons
uh
prompt equals to await sorry await
request of Json so later on what we
going to do is when we press shift a
here we can to take the latest like May
30 characters and we can to pass into
this prom here prom object from variable
here so now we can actually request for
the response right so we do cons
response it goes to open away open ai.
create chat completion we'll see the
model will be uh gbd d3.5 dturbo
for the messages right so we're going to
have the first message being the system
message to promp the system what his R
is supposed to be so we'll tell it that
hey uh you are a helpful
AI actually I'm just going to copy in
and just going to uh just tell you what
is because it's quite a long
prompt okay so here let me just copy
here can I just copy this
content all right so let's see here okay
so I basically tell you that you're an
helpful AI EMB bettered in a notion text
editor app that's used to autocomplete
sentences so the trait of AI include
expert knowledge helpfulness cleverness
and articulateness is a well behaved and
well-mannered individual and it's always
friendly kind and inspiring and is eager
to provide Vivid and thoughtful
responses so we're just basically
prompting the AI on what we expect for
the responses to be like so after that
we can create another message and this
time will be the the user to the user
right so the content of the user will be
uh let me just copy this in so leave all
this in a paste bin down below so you
can just copy from there so you have to
like type it out manually so for the
user will be saying I'm writing a piece
of text in the notion text editor app
help me complete my train of thought
here and we pass in the promt so this
promt comes from this request body and
then we want to keep the tone of the
text consistent with the rest of the
text and keep the response short and
sweet so this is some prompt engineer
ing to make sure that the W output is uh
is good and last want to pass in the
stream stream passing the stream to true
so this stream will then basically allow
the open a API to pass in like tokens
like one by one instead of like waiting
for the entire response to finish before
passing us back so better user
experience and lastly we want to do cons
stream equals to open eii Stream So this
open AI stream comes from this AI
library right and we'll pass in the
response
okay and then we'll do return a new
streaming text response from o from AI
so so this streaming text response
function passing in the
Stream uh stream okay so this will
basically return us with a a streaming
uh streaming content type that we can
injust in the front end to basically uh
mimic the streaming response when we
press shift a all right so that's go we
have finished the backend end point it's
pretty simple po just Heating and some
prom engineering so let's close this
down so come back to our tip tab editor
okay uh we can have a we're going to use
a new a hook from we going to import
this hook so let me show you what Hook
is
from SL from AI SL react so under the
react library from from AI has a used
completion hook so this used completion
hook will allow us to interact with the
backend API that we have just written is
able to return us with the streaming
tokens as we like uh manual trigger the
AI completion so the first thing here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
just take a
cons equals to use completion I'll
passing the API to be/ API
completion
completion okay so this API is the roots
to whatever whatever back end here and
it has to return a it has to return a uh
streaming text response so this is ma to
the root that we just done for this comp
completion here okay because it Maps to/
API completion so it has to match here
so we're telling you what API root it is
and we can destructure a few things we
can destructure the complete and the
completion so this complete is a
function that we call to trigger the
completion to basically trigger the end
point and this completion is a bunch of
is just like a a react state to get back
all the tokens okay so what I'm going to
do here is
a uh underneath here underneath here uh
because here we know that we want to
activate the eii right I'm going to Do
complete so I'm going to call the
complete uh function and pass in the
prom so this promt is basically uh let's
get the last 30 characters so let's do
uh take the last 30 words so we'll just
do cons prompt equals to this.
editor do uh
get
text so this will get all the pl text do
splits do slice uh sorry dot uh sorry
split on the empty empty space right
space and slice it by
30-3 and we just join it back with a
empty space so let me just console lock
out the prom so we see what is happening
here so whenever press shift a we should
get the latest 30 words right so let me
just show you so let me like type in a
bunch of stuff if I press shift a we can
see that it gets back this uh this of 30
30 words right okay so now we to fit
this 30 words into the completion uh end
point so that's called complete on the
promt itself okay and what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to show you the I'm
going to use effect use effect to
basically uh console lock out the
completion so remember here it also
returns us with this completion variable
so I'm going to show you what it looks
like console
completion I'm going to save it so for
now I'm going to delete everything else
and let's just type some something
serious like let's
say uh I like cats okay I'm going to
press shift a it's going to trigger the
thing and watch what happen soon right
yeah so you can see this completion is
coming back do you see
this yeah so you can see that cats with
their charming and things like that so
this is the the completion variable so
the issue you can see is that every time
this completion it just like streams in
token by token right so into then into
the world then becomes into the world
com uh full stop
so how do we actually get that
individual word so because right we want
to get the individual word uh get in the
vual word so that we can insert into the
editor right the issue right now is
because I have this function let me show
you here so I'm going to do uh editor
dot commands do uh insert content I can
insert the completion right but I'm
going to show you the issue here so let
me just do editor
so uh if not
editor
return so let's actually move this down
below the
editor so let me show you the issue
right now so basically every time the
completion changes I'm going to insert
this new completion into whatever text
editor I have here so let me show you
the issue right now okay so
I like head okay Watch What Happens
press shift a and look it's going to
give us a bunch of JB look at this this
is not right this is not right why
because every time this completion
changes this completion is a whole
another paragraph So if you keep like
basically uh if you keep inserting
content it's going to insert like all
this junk paragraph because it's
duplicated the completion is duplicated
right we can see that uh uh here is
duplicated it comes like token by token
so we actually want to get the
individual token that comes back from
the completion and to do that we can
actually have a we can save we can use a
clever trick we can just do uh cons last
completion equals to react. use ref
passing empty string okay so then what
we can do is here we can have a react
cons uh token equals to react. use memo
so this used memo is a is to memorize
the function to memorize the calculation
right so every time the completion comes
back in we're going to do
uh uh we're going to basically take the
difference between the completion and
the last completion so let us do uh let
us actually get the memo let me just
check okay so so if not completion we're
going to return but then if there's a
completion we got to just do cons div
equals to completion slice so we get the
whole paragraph and then just want to
like uh take the difference between the
whole paragraph and the last completion
so that we can get the individual token
that was actually returned from the back
end so we'll slice by
the uh pre uh last completion do
currents do
length Okay and then we can just return
the diff so this will return us with the
individual tokens and I can prove it by
instead of this completion let me just
delete this I'll put in token and let me
just put in this token and actually
console. loock
token so if it's not not token we return
okay so let me prove to you why this
will work right now so let me just save
it here again
so if I delete the whole thing again I
WR I like cat and this time if I press
shift a we can see the tokens start
coming back in see it's in addition
right
yeah so right now it's still uh it's
still not working and the reason why is
because let me show you uh if not
completion right because after we have
set the after we have set the diff we
will still need to set the last
completion current to be completion so
after we have already take the
difference we want to set the last
completion so that it finishes the loop
and then we can uh get the latest token
again so let me try again so I like cats
okay so let me open up the console here
okay so I was debugging something but um
I'm actually not really sure why it
doesn't work or why it works but anyways
we were talking about how we're trying
to get back the individual tokens from
the uh completion string right so what
we did was we did a react use effect so
whenever the completion came back we
basically keep track of a last
completion which is a ref right so this
ref will not change will not rerender
the whole component whatever it changes
so it's very good to like just keep
track of what the last completion was so
uh every time this completion changes we
got to basically take the last comp
completion and we got to take the
difference between the last completion
and the completion so then we got to get
back the individual individual token so
this diff represent the individual token
and then uh we can just set the last
completion to be the current completion
and we just take the editor and we
insert the diff the token into the
editor so right now it can't it works
right now so I can just do like um cats
and docks R right so if I zoom in I can
press shift a and it should just give me
back a nice a streaming effect where it
just automat adds it into the text
editor and it saves it automatically
yeah so we refresh it and it saves yeah
so that's how the completion Works uh
yes yes yes so I hope you understand
that part so it's just about
manipulating and using the use
completion Hook from versal Ai and then
trying to get the difference and to get
the actual individual token to then
insert the individual tokens into the
editor y okay so we have completed U
pretty much the bo of the application we
get to like edit it with b and like
things like that and we also did like
the auto complete by pressing shift a so
let me just the last step here is just
to help me uh add like the the UI change
for this like a tip press shift a for
the auto compete so let's add that part
in here okay so uh come down to this uh
inside the under the editor content here
right so we got remember we got this
Pros right uh for this proos actually
let's add one more class name for it let
us add this
pr-sm uh with full and margin top of
four then underne this diff let have a
height of four so it's a spacer diff
empty div and here we can add a keyboard
uh command so we'll give it a span of
text SM and then let's give it a tip
press uh so let's give you a kbd so it's
a special keyboard element in HTML shift
plus a and let's give it a styling so
class name of
padding X of two padding y of 1 padding
y of
1.5 uh Tex super small XS font of semi
bolt Tex gray of 900 sorry tax of 800 um
BG gray of 100 border border Dash gray
of 200 and rounded Dash
large and then underneath here shift a
let's do for AI auto complete so if we
save that right now here we got this so
let me add one more spacing some spacing
in front of it here so like this and
then here we can also add a spacing like
this okay so now it looks good so we got
command to like tell people what to do
to actually uh do the auto complete so
that's perfect that's
perfect okay so uh now that we have
finished it let's actually go back to
build our uh dashboard page so right now
the the dashboard has only this new uh
this notebook so now let's actually
fetch all the notebooks and display in a
grid layout here so I'm just going to
come down and let me just close out all
my tabs so we are more organized so come
down here close my tabs and let's come
back to our dashboard page okay so let's
dis all the notes but first let's
actually get all the notes okay so for
the dashboard page what we need to do is
uh since let's Mak it into a server
component and then let's actually fetch
it okay so let's do cons user ID equals
to off right so make sure that uh the
user is log in then we do cons notes
equals to await db.
select from dollar sign notes
where uh
where
equals uh notes. user ID equals to user
ID so add exclamation mark So that we
ensure that the user will always be here
so now we get back a list of all the
notes that belongs to this user that is
log in so now let's actually look
through it right so below here inside
this grid layout so remember here uh
this conditionally render so let's
actually do the thing so uh if no not
display this so let's do uh notes.
length equals to zero if so basically if
there's no notes then it Mak sense to
display this uh uh text string that we
have no
notes okay so if you have notes let's
come down here so underneath the create
note dialogue so let's do notes. map so
for each note Let Us return a uh normal
a tech so a normal anchor tag so we have
H ref equals to SL notes slash not sorry
slash notes
uh notes. ID okay so let's give you a
key
of notes. ID all right within the the
anchor tech let's actually add a uh diff
so this diff will be the card so we have
a overflow of hidden Flex Flex of column
when it's when we hover over it let's
have a shadow of XL
transition when we when we hover over
again we negative Translate Y of one so
within the card here let us show an uh
image so let me show an image first let
me give you a width of 400 and a height
of height of 200 and we'll give it out
of notes. name and finally a
source note. name and the source Pro
will be notes. image URL all right so
some it might be now so let us do empty
string if it doesn't
exist okay then underneath here let's
actually save it first so now we are
able to see okay we got the cat and the
dog right let me let me let me show you
why the image is not showing up first so
let's come down below inside the diff
below the image let's have another diff
they have a class name of padding of
four and then have a H3 so this H will
have a class name of text XL font
semi B text grade of 900 then within the
H Tre let us put notes. name underneath
the H Tre let's have a spacer of H1
height of one so it's empty diff and
we'll finally have a paragraph tag that
have a class name
of text smm text Gray of 500 within the
paragraph tag that us show new date
notes. created at
right dot to local date
string okay let's save it and right now
it should show up nicely okay the date
does not exist so it's a capital D so
let's save it and okay showing so now we
got this uh date here and stuff so uh
the reason why is not uh there's one
more thing I'm missing let me see what
I'm missing okay
overflow things like
that okay so uh one more thing for this
diff on this overflow hidden let's just
add round rounded large so that is a
little more
rounded okay so it shows up nicely here
and if you go back to like refer back to
our thing uh let's hope that it looks
similar okay perfect so there's actually
another a border around it so let's
actually add a border so we'll do
uh border border
stone stone of 200
okay so it looks nicer now perfect
perfect yeah okay so uh the issue right
now is why is the image is not showing
up is let actually go inspect into our
uh our drizzle kit I'm going to show you
what is the issue so we just do MPX
drizzle kit Studio to open up your
database client in the
website all right so open this up okay
look at this image URL I'm going to copy
this image URL I'm going to paste it in
the URL right is going to tell us that
he has he has expired so the the reason
is because open AI open AI uh D open AI
d uh
to
expiry right so uh by default d 2 gives
you about I think two hour after an hour
so the URL that's generated like this
URL is only valid for an hour so after
an hour this URL will no longer be valid
so it's actually up to us the developers
to save this temporary URL to another uh
per perent storage in this case this
permanent storage I'll be using Firebase
so to actually uh store this let's
actually go to Firebase console so
search for the Firebase console and you
have to log in or register for an
account so Firebase is like a is a back
end as a service to give you that uh
give you a lot of functionalities like
authentication and storage so once you
log into the dashboard come down to add
a project so create a new project and
for the project let's call it uh uh
ideation D YouTube
then press continue and uh we don't to
enable Google analytics just press
create project and it's going to wait
for it to create the project okay so now
that the project is ready let's press
continue okay so we'll be brought to the
uh ideation YouTube plan uh to the
dashboard in this case we want to uh
activate the storage right so come down
to the sidebar and you should be able to
find let's see if I'm able to activate
it if I zoom out a little okay uh come
down to the the sidebar and I want to
search for the storage so storage here
so retrieve user generated content so
here is where we going to store our our
images P the the jpex so let's press get
started in the storage and start in test
mode so that um we able to access it so
then press on next and then lastly it's
saying that this is where our default go
storage bucket is set so let's choose a
location that's near us so in this case
I will choose uh Asia South is one so CH
somewh that's closer to you okay and
then after done let me actually then
just come and press done on the bottom
right corner my head is blocking but
yeah so we are creating a bucket meaning
that we are choosing a location nearest
to us to store all our uh D images so
we're going wait for you to create the
default bucket and then I'm I'm going to
teach you how to actually set up the
Firebase to connect to the
storage okay so when the bucket has
finished in initializing we have to
create a new web project so uh is a
create a new website that can is able to
consume these images so come down to the
project and just press web right so
we're going to create a new web app so
you can name it whatever you want I'm
going to create just name it my web app
and we don't want to we just disable
Firebase hosting and I'll Press Register
App and it should be able to give us uh
all API keys to connect from our web
application onto this Firebase okay so
let's follow it so we need to install
this Firebase package so it's okay so
let's come down to our terminal and
let's just stop the dzo studio and do
mpm install Firebase all
right so once we have installed Firebase
let's see what is next uh sorry uh what
happened to our thing one app my web
app okay so after we have installed
Firebase right we need to copy this uh
code into our Firebase uhts so come down
here and close the terminal come down to
our uh lip so under our library we got
to create a new file called
Firebase TTS and we'll basically just
copy in whatever code is here so press
copy and just copy here so I'm going to
you have to blank out your uh API key
here okay blank out your API key so what
you going to do is going to copy
whatever you have here cut it out and go
into your EnV and let us do uh actually
let me see yes we have to
do
Firebase API key and just paste it in
here okay then with this you can then
come back here and just
do process. env. Firebase API key cuz we
do not want to upload this into our like
how say we don't want to upload this
into our G repository for everyone to
see all right so after you have this you
can then close the Firebase tab all
right so the next step for the Firebase
is want to initialize the storage right
so uh underneath here we'll do export
cons storage equals to get storage so
this get storage will come from uh
Firebase storage so import get
storage from Firebase SL
storage so get storage and passing the
app instance here so this storage is
what we will be using to interact and
upload all our files onto um a 5way
storage basically so let's save that
okay so let us now talk about the flow
so right now if you come back to your uh
create a uh create notebook rout create
notebook rout here right we can see that
uh we're returning this note ID and then
after we have created it so we create
note dialogue right remember that after
we have um created this new note we are
directly navigating to this notebook so
before we navigate it right we actually
want to hit another endpoint hit another
endpoint to upload the temporary uh di
URL to permanent uh fire base URL okay
so let's set up the endpoint to upload
the image the temporary D image to the
permanent permanent Firebase uh storage
so come down to your app directory come
down to your API folder and then let's
do upload to
Firebase let's create roots. TS within
this
Firebase okay and now let's actually
work on this okay so uh let me see if I
can find it all right so let me just
export a async function called post
which will take in the request object
and let's actually do the uh try catch
so we're going to accept a a note ID
from the request. Json await request.
Json uh Asing function export Asing
function await request. Json so we'll be
expecting a notes ID from
this so what we going to do is after we
we have uh got created a new node here
right we're going to basically hit this
Endo hit the end point passing in the
node ID then from this note ID we uh
will then extract out the extract out
the DI image URL then save it to
Firebase okay so hope you understand
that part so let's get the image URL so
we'll just do cons note equals to await
DB do select from dollar sign noes where
equals uh so you want to equal to the
par in uh sorry the do sign notes. ID
and the par in notes ID
okay so this will be notes so then we're
going to check if not notes uh notes
index zero. image URL so if the D to uh
image URL doesn't exist that means
something went wrong so let's return a
new uh next next response saying that no
image URL passing in a status of 400
okay now we will try to uh upload the
file to Firebase so let's actually
create a new uh how say underneath the
come down to your fire base. TS right
write a function below here to actually
upload the
file okay okay so uh so we're going to
write a function export e sync function
right which will uh which will be called
upload file to
Firebase so it's going to take in the
image URL which is a string and a prompt
which is also a string so this prom is
just to name the file just to give the
file a name so let me just name it as
name here okay so the first step is
actually let's do a try catch block so
we'll try to get the
response equals await fetch so this is
the native fetch URL a fetch API and we
fetch the image URL so this image URL
remember this is the D 2 AP the D 2
temporary temporary image URL okay so we
await it and then we'll get the the
buffer equals to await uh response.
array buffer so this will convert the uh
image into array buffer and now we can
just do uh cons file name equals to
name. replace want to replace all uh uh
space characters with just an empty
string and we'll just add uh uh dates do
now
plus jpeg so we're just renaming the
file to add a custom ID and then make
sure it's a JPEG
format now we can do cons storage ref so
we want to get the reference in the
Firebase storage equals to ref so this
ref is from the Firebase storage we pass
in the storage object from this uh get
storage here right and then we pass in
the uh file name okay so then after we
got the storage ref so now we got a
reference to that actual file we can
then upload the image to that file so we
do await upload bytes so this upload BYT
is also from Firebase storage we pass in
the which reference we want to upload to
we pass in the buffer okay so this
buffer contains the actual image right
and then uh we want to finally tell it
that the content type is a image/ JPEG
cuz we're trying to upload a JPEG image
up to the storage okay and then finally
at the end we can just do cons Firebase
URL it goes to await gets download URL
from Firebase storage passing in the
storage ref so these are all just uh I
read documentation and figure it out
myself right so I'm just stealing it
down for you in this simple code snippet
telling you how to get the image URL and
uploading it to
Firebase in the end we just want to
return the Firebase URL so we're going
this is the permanent Ur URL now and
then if there's an error any error let's
just console.log console. error out the
error
okay so now we got this function
actually call it so come down to your
create not uh come down to your uh uh
upload to Firebase route again and this
time we're going to then call um let me
see so after we got the image URL let us
do cons
Firebase URL equals to await upload a
file to Firebase pass in passing in the
notes notes. image URL okay and then we
pass in the name here okay so does this
make sense so because this upload file
to Firebase remember it takes the image
DRL and the name so you're just passing
in the D URL and the the name of it so
it's going to basically take the d URL
it's going to put it into Firebase
storage and return us with this Firebase
URL so then finally we want to save this
Firebase URL to the permanent database
okay so let us do await db. update
dollar sign notes do set
uh image URL to be the filebase URL and
then where equals notes. ID equals to
pass in node ID so we're just updating
the image URL to the the permanent
Firebase URL when the note ID equals to
the passin node ID from the body and
then lastly we can just return a new
next response of true and the status of
200 then if there's any
error uh sorry okay okay and if there's
any error we just return a uh error and
a internal server error code okay
perfect so now we've got this uh
endpoint that's actually call it so come
back to your uh come back to your how
say create uh create note dialogue right
got this create notebook mutation let's
create another mutation for the
uploading of the Firebase so we do
uh let us actually get the Firebase root
so let me just do this uh cons upload to
fire base this is going to be use
mutation the mutation function this time
will be async right cons response
response equals to
await
exos post SL API SL upload to
Firebase right and passing in the notes
ID so let me just delete this okay so
this API SL upload to Firebase this is
the roots that we created just now right
this this roote this uh upload to
filebase root right so remember it needs
two things right it needs no sorry it
needs one thing we need a note ID so the
note ID will be uh how do we actually
get the note ID we can get it from the
props itself right so let's get the note
so uh so to get the note ID we can get
it from the parameters parameter so we
can just pass in the notes
ID okay and then we can just return
response. data so let me just walk you
through what we're doing first I'll
write out the code then I'll explain so
after we have uh created a new note
let's actually also do upload to
Firebase
mutate uh passing in the note ID so
after we have created the note right we
got the note ID the newly created Noe ID
then we got to call this upload to
filebase mutate passing this Noe ID this
no ID will then be propagated up here to
this new ID this mutation function and
you going to be hitting this upload
filebase API with this new ID ID and
then we going to just take the temporary
D API and then convert it into the
Firebase URL and then we can just return
response. data and just save it so then
it's going to basically convert our di
image into the Firebase uh storage so
let's actually try out so I'm going to
refresh the page and let's see if it
actually works okay so I'm going to just
uh create a new notebook and this time
I'm going to call it let's say uh type
script and let's create so let's look
into the cont cons for any errors so
it's going to basically start creating
the notebook so the first create
notebook route is going to handle uh the
creation of the images uh the D image
and then here we can see that there's an
error right it says that uh this
encoding library is not found so we
actually need to install this encoding
library for it to work so just do mpm
install encoding okay and lastly let's
go back here and let's see if it still
won't work for now course we need to try
again actually it works so we can see
that this uh URL is now uploaded to the
Firebase storage so you come down to the
resz studio right so let's do MPX
drizzle kit
studio right so if we refresh this we
can now see the typescript has a
Firebase URL so this Firebase storage
this Firebase URL is permanent for else
this is temporarily okay so everything
works fine everything is perfect
everything is working good so the last
thing here is uh instead of using this
um instead of using the default image
we're going to use the next next uh SL
image so import this next SL image
component so it will help us optimize
our image further if you save it right
now it's going to throw an error right
because let me show you why it's going
to say that this uh host name is not
configured so we actually need to add
this a Firebase storage host name to our
configuration so let me just copy this
uh this Firebase storage. uh Firebase
storage. googleapis.com let's copy this
this and let me just come down to my
next config.js so inside this config I
need to basically allow and white list
this image a domain so we do
images right passing in the domains to
be an array and it's going to basically
allow any images from the Firebase
storage so let's save it and let's
actually delete the previous two records
so I'm going to choose these two records
and delete it delete and now I'm going
to refresh the the I'm going to refresh
the server so do mpm so right now it's
it stopped right
so let's do
refresh sorry let us see if we able to
get it up and running
again and now it works okay so now we're
using the the we're using the how to say
we're using the next SL image component
and let's actually try it again so let's
create a new notebook and this time
let's call it uh something creative like
let's
say computer Graphics let's see what
kind of Graphics is able to generate so
you hit the API it will generate the D
to image and then you will redirect us
to the uh notes note page right and then
you will then in the meantime in the
background you will upload that di API
into our Firebase storage so we can see
that configur Graphics is Right written
here I can press shift a and it's able
to generate uh the auto complete for us
so that's beautiful everything is
working perfectly okay then it's
automatically it to the database and
then when we press back it then we can
refresh the page and it's able to see
the computer graphics and this image is
then uploaded into Firebase so yeah I
think that's it for the for everything
actually one more thing
is so right now if you press like if you
press here it brings you to SL notes
which is incorrect so it should bring
you to SL notebook instead so let me
come down here to this so instead of
leading to sln notes SL notes book so
let's save it and let's try again so if
I press this then it correctly brings me
to the typescript page all right that's
perfect that's
perfect and last but not least let's
actually do the delete button okay it's
a pretty simple component so come down
to your components let us do components
create a delete button. TSX so TS r f c
okay so for the delete button let us you
try to accept the notes ID right which
is a
number so let us destructure the note ID
so this is will tell uh our database
which note to delete so then we're going
to do uh let us actually render the
button so return a
button that have uh variance of
destructive so it's red color and then
we'll here have a trash icon so this
trash is from Luc react and then
basically let us give it a size of small
and then onclick so when we click on it
let us actually confirm to the user
first so cons confirm equals to window.
confirm are you are you sure you want to
delete this notes question mark So if
not confirm we want to return so they're
trying to delete the operation but if
they confirm it that means we actually
want to call the API function so let let
us create a new endpoint in apepi let's
create a folder called delete noes and
let's create a root. TS so it's the same
thing let us do export
async function post taking the request
to be
request and now let's actually get the
cons notes ID equals to await request.
Json so we get the no ID from the
request body and then we can do await DB
do
delete uh delete from so delete uh
notes where equals uh dollar sign notes.
ID equals to par in notes ID okay so
then we got to just return new next
response of sorry new next response
of
uh okay and passing a status of
200 okay
so yeah it's just a simple function to
take in the Noe ID and just return it so
let me just save it and come back to the
button and we can then take the mutation
so let's actually convert this into a
client component first and we can just
take the mutation function so cons
delete noes equals to news
mutation passing in the mutate function
to be async we are going to hit and
point right so we do cons response
equals to A W exos post post slash API
SL sorry SL API
SL delete notes right so this is the
rout that we created just now right
passing in the notes
id id right which we receive from props
and then we just want to
return response. data okay so then if
confirm we going do delete uh notes.
mutate we could passing undefined
because it's not accepting any
parameters and then on success we just
going to just uh do we going basically
route them back to the dashboard so
let's get the router so we just do cons
router equals to use router from make
sure it's from next SL navigation not
next
router okay and then we're going to do
uh router. push
dashboard yeah then if there are any
errors on error
we're just going to console. error error
so let's save it and then let's actually
import this delete button so come down
to your uh notes ID uh to your note page
so remember where we put
our where do we put our delete button
here okay so let's just import the
delete button so do delete button right
need to pass in the notes ID which will
be notes. ID so now let's save it and
now have a delete button showing up here
so if you press delete you ask us for
the confirmation then let's actually add
one more thing so we want to disable the
button when the delete notes dot is
loading so while it's loading we want to
disable the button so let's try again so
it's going to ask me to confirm when I
press okay it's going to try to delete
and it will just come back and we can
see the note has been deleted so yeah
everything works perfectly and yeah I
think that's good yeah everything looks
exactly the same and I'm pretty happy
with what we have completed so far so I
think if I'm not wrong that's everything
everything you need to know uh about the
application all right so um I'm glad I'm
very happy that you did this with me
it's a very quick and simple build this
time not very long but it showcase a lot
of the power of artificial intelligence
and the open a API so the last step here
is I'm going to teach you how to deploy
to uh versel right it's going to be very
simple so the first step here is come
down to github.com New we going to
basically push this repository to a new
GitHub repo all right so uh I can do is
I'm going to expand the screen move the
screen here so the repository name you
can name it whever you want and going
just put ideation D YouTube and you can
put it as public or private up to you
and just press create
repository so after you have created
repository you have to follow the the
commands here so come back to your vs
code come back to your terminal I'm
going to stop everything running okay
stop everything running here uh yes and
then I'm going to do git status to make
sure that everything here is added so
let's do git at all then get commit D am
initial commit so we commit our all
changes now we can do git Branch DM so
to rename our Branch to main if you have
not done so already and then we can add
the origin right so basically linking
our local repo to the remote repo and
lastly we can just run git push d u
origin mean to then push our code up to
the the the
repo so now let if we refresh the page
we can see that all changes is up here
so that's perfect okay so now let's
actually deploy it so there's one more
there I think there's uh two more things
I to do so come down to your uh create a
note rout create notebook root right so
to make this into a run on H the H run
time right remember the benefits of H
runtime it allows your function to run
longer and faster so you have to export
a runtime export cons run runtime equals
to H so if you export this runtime
variable uh next year versel will detect
it automatically and you will deploy
this function on the H runtime instead
of the normal nodejs run time okay and
one more thing is come down to your uh
next config.js and just add the
typescript flag right to ignore during
ignore the build errors and for the es
link to ignore uh during builds to be
true so yeah this just for the versal
deployment then after that you can just
commit it again so I'm going to use the
graphic user interface so I'm just going
to move H function so just commit it and
push it out so this is the last two
things I think yeah so if you come back
back up here we can refresh and we're
able to see our changes uh hopefully
let's refresh one more time and yeah so
we can see that our fun our comits being
done now Edge comit Edge function so to
deploy versel is really simple come down
to ver.com
and come back to the dashboard and add a
new project so add new project project
and choose your uh report that you have
just linked up so just press import and
can just name it whatever you want here
and then choose the build setting so for
the not sorry build the environmental
variables so come down to your EnV here
so a neat trick for you is press command
a or control a if you're on Windows to
select everything and then copy it come
back to verel and can just paste it in
here it's able to copy and detect all
your enval variables in here with that
you can just press deploy and then
everything should be well and in a few
minutes uh it should be building and
just Deploy on that easily so I'll see
you when it's finished building okay so
wait one more thing I want to do is uh
come back to your come back to your
dashboard here come back into your
application come on to your settings and
for the functions right I want you to
choose one that is nearest to you in
this case I CH live in Singapore so I'm
going to choose Singapore and save it
all right so this is just to make sure
that the the function the apis uh will
be very near you so that the user
experience be very fast yeah so that's
pretty much it so come back to your
deployments and we're just waiting for
it to build yeah so I'll see you on the
other
side okay so it has been deployed
successfully so now let us just visit
the domain that have he has given us so
let's actually try out and see and hope
that it works so we can see that yeah
not taking assistant or typ is working
so let's press get started and it should
promise to log in so just log in with
your uh
account and hopefully it will bring us
to the dashboard where we're able to see
all notes that we have done okay uh and
then we can see the images will show up
soon right let's try creating a new
notebook let's create cats let's create
and hopefully hopefully the age run time
will work and does not time out on
me okay so it works it works okay that's
amazing so we can see that it brings us
to the new notebook and we can type
whatever you want here like uh press
shift a and we can see the AI Auto
completion still works perfectly it's
deployed up here and yeah we can see
that uh it automatically saves it right
wait for it to save I can itze it and do
everything like that and yeah I think
that that looks perfect and if you come
back to the homepage and refresh we can
see that the DI 2 API should have
generated image for us yeah and it's a
cute little kidden pause things like
that yeah so I'm glad that you are here
with this journey so today we learned a
lot so let me just recap what we have
learned so we learn about next 13 how to
style it properly with SH CN how to use
the open AI with the di uh generator
verel AG runtime I told you how to use
drizzo RM to interact with neon DB how
to use Firebase storage to actually
store your files uh and also the tip tab
uh Editor to actually give you the power
to create the notion like editor and the
versel AI is a ke for all the streaming
AI large language model need so um I'm
happy that you stay with me so if you
enjoy and learn something from the video
please like comment and subscribe I put
in a lot of effort for this kind of
videos and I hope you'll really learn
something new and with that thank you
for so much for watching and have a good
day